hey guys pete here
let's talk about better call saul season
six episode six
acts and grind felt like the final
installment in the first half of the
season's setup episodes and ended on a
point of no return
we got a flashback and a character
return
we got a lot of interesting stuff going
on in the background
and it kind of jumped all over the place
in tone there were funny moments dark
and dangerous moments and even some more
moments between the characters
but at the end of the day it all comes
down to the choice kim makes at the end
what's what is that going to mean for
her and what is that going to mean for
howard
these are the big questions
i invited some of my friends to come and
discuss this episode with me like we do
every tuesday
i'm gonna give them a chance to
introduce themselves and give me a quick
overview of what they thought about the
episode
overall just the you know the whole
thing how it worked what worked what
didn't work
and then i'll respond to that and we'll
jump in and we'll go
character to character and talk about
what happened and our thoughts on that
so gil why don't you go first and let's
uh let me know what you think about this
episode sounds good yeah for me this was
pretty similar in tone to the last
couple of episodes where there's a lot
of humor with the sort of undercurrent
of suspense in a dark cloud hanging over
everything i feel like the omaha beach
scene in this latest episode jimmy and
kim sitting outside hhm at night where
it feels like the night before a battle
when everything's gonna go wrong
that has kind of been the thing hanging
over these episodes and as we get closer
and closer to d-day for me the pit in my
stomach has kind of gotten stronger and
stronger
and in the meantime as we approach that
day i do feel like there's some table
setting for example letting us get to
know howard a little bit more so when
the inevitable fallout comes we feel all
the stuff we're supposed to feel you
know if tragedy befalls howard now we're
gonna feel even worse about it than we
would have a couple of seasons ago when
we didn't know him as well and we're
poking and prodding jimmy and kim a
little bit finding out why they're
really doing all this
where do they stand morally we're
learning bits and pieces
and uh but i am definitely at the point
now where i'm ready to see
what happens what is the big thing
coming if there's a big thing coming in
the mid-season finale
i think there better be um
every all signs are pointing to it uh it
may be a cliffhanger but i think we're
gonna definitely see some stuff
develop
how about you jim
uh yeah i like this episode i i
the last three episodes i think are
taken sort of as a trio um
they felt very similar i think they'll
probably be even better on re-watch
because you can just sort of binge right
through them and then get to this next
episode which like you gill i'm
i'm hoping there's some point to it i'm
hoping that this kind of blows me away
um
and they're they're setting up pretty
big expectations for that so
uh yeah i want to see them deliver on
that i
i do like also getting some some little
cutaways to some of the other characters
this episode like lalo and mike um
lalo
i i appreciated that they skipped the
part where he goes and tracks down
volkers or whatever the name of the
institution that
uh they got the the
plaque or the acrylic thing printed at
um he just kind of goes directly to the
guys right uh and he's tracked one of
them down and we didn't need to see all
that other stuff with mike
you know i kind of know who mike is
already but seeing this moment with his
daughter and his granddaughter
uh just before
the [ __ ] really hits the fan probably
um i i think was a nice little
hey let's just catch up and then because
next week is going to be crazy so
i i'm really hoping we do get that crazy
episode next week
yeah i i thought that the mic scene at
first it felt a little out of place um
but i was i was with you jim there i
thought that it did it was a nice um
just like a nice look at him and where
he's at he's kind of sucked into this
thing
that's sort of kind of how the story's
playing out right and um it's connected
to what happened with the super lab and
the job he took there which should have
been
pretty easy and low risk and everything
else and and now you know he he can't
he's got to tell his granddaughter that
he's uh you know in chattanooga and
watcher from distance
and it shows like what matters to him
what he's fighting for
and you know we'll talk about this more
in a minute but um
i thought overall yeah i like this we i
like this week a bit better um
i like that they didn't they didn't
present the actual plan to us to say hey
look this is what we're doing
but they put all the clues there where
we could actually figure it out now and
we actually can tell what's happening
there and you know they trusted us to be
able to put that together and it's
always fun when you get to be like oh
you know i figured it out i'm so smart
or whatever and um i agree with both of
you guys uh you know these three
episodes they were fine
you know it was a setup uh but now i am
you know ready to find out where it's
all going because you know like we were
talking before we started
they were keeping us in the dark on
purpose especially through those first
two
and now you know it's time for a little
bit of payoff and uh i'm looking forward
to that i think um
i think that that's about it i think we
could probably jump straight in here i i
was saying earlier it kind of jumps all
over the place and it really is about
kim
but i thought we would go through and
talk about the other characters first so
that way we can just sort of stay on kim
and jimmy and what's going on there when
we get to it
so i thought we should start out with
howard
um
who's currently living in the guest
house
he's got this wonderful
i guess it's a villa maybe you would
call that and
he doesn't actually stay there and his
wife does though and it's pretty um
pretty rough scene there where he's
making coffee and you're watching him do
this like
almost a ritual to make this great cup
with the peace sign on top in the foam
and then we find out how their
relationship really is whenever he gives
it to her she barely looks at it dumps
it in her travel mug and can't wait to
get out of the room like she's just not
there you know it's not this is not what
she wants to uh
this conversation or just talking to her
husband at all is not something she's
interested in doing
um this is sandrine holt they brought in
and she's kind of working her way into a
decent percentage of my favorite tv
shows now she was on the expanse she was
in mrs mr robot
and um
glad to see her show up i do wonder a
little bit if we're gonna see more of
her or if this was just a
you know five minutes this is what it is
and that's all we really need to know
and um
i don't know what did you guys
i i thought that you know howard is a
guy that
he was he was presented as an
obstruction to what jimmy and kim were
trying to do for most of the early
seasons we weren't really supposed to
like him he's super charismatic in his
way and you know he's a likable guy
and so you do a bit
but the last couple of seasons they
leaned into making him more sympathetic
you know after chuck's death he he went
through a hard time he he came out on
the other side kind of did things the
right way
while jimmy just sort of went in a
different direction
and now you know we're seeing this stuff
it all feels like we're supposed to feel
bad for this character and we're not
supposed to want what's going to happen
to him to happen and i don't really know
what that says about his fate because
it's really hard to imagine
this guy like dying or something like
that
you know it's just that this
of course they kill people all the time
and that always is at risk when you're
in this universe
but it feels it feels a little harsh
you know for how things have been set up
so what do you guys think about this um
opening scene with howard and what he's
got going on with his wife there
uh i've liked it because it gives an
insight into
who howard is outside of his job and
we've never had that before
the the therapist discussion he had last
week didn't really
give us any actual insight it just sort
of hinted at what was going on
uh and so actually getting in there and
seeing it yeah it does sympathize howard
even more um
we don't really know why he's on the
rocks with his wife at this point which
i think is interesting um
so so i'm not like totally on his side
yet i don't want to just give him the
bend for the doubt that you know he did
nothing wrong and uh she's just
you know sticking it to him for no
reason but at the same time
i've seen howard i've seen especially
who he's become in the last two seasons
i don't know why that guy would be in
such hot water at this point with his
spouse so
i am sort of inclined to give him the
benefit of the doubt
yeah it's funny because i feel like his
conversation with the therapist did not
do justice to just how bad things are
between him and his wife i think the
line we heard was that they don't talk
about any of the important stuff so to
me it sounded maybe like she's just kind
of shutting him out
but in that scene she is blatantly i
think trying to jab at him taking that
coffee and pouring it into her travel
mug spilling it like that was a very
intentional look how much i don't care
about the effort that you just put in
and you didn't even clean it up whenever
she walked yeah yeah
so
it's really hard to watch and to your
point jim we don't know what got them to
this point so we can't really put a
judgment on it and say who's right who's
wrong does he deserve this
but
the writers know that we don't have the
context so all they're showing us
is a guy who's trying and
his wife is
not reciprocating at all so it's hard
not to feel bad for him i do think it
seems like howard went through a pretty
major change after chuck's death
the namaste license plate and just his
overall attitude trying to write things
with jimmy so who knows maybe before
that he was an awful husband maybe he
was terrible and it's just too much to
make up for who knows but in any case i
think i
felt about it the same way both of you
did you can't watch the scene and not
feel bad for him which makes me really
worry for his fate
you know i don't know it's actually
funny somebody in the chat mentioned
maybe jimmy and kim will sneak the drugs
to him and he'll end up having a heart
attack or something and i had that exact
thought about an hour ago right before
we sat down to do this
i am worried about him i'm worried and
i'm especially worried after this scene
yeah that was the only thing that the um
about the drug that sounded like it
might be a bad situation for howard was
he made the point of saying something
about caffeine and
in in this scene when he's making the
coffee he's actually drinking tea and i
don't even know if it's it could be
herbal tea for for what you can see so
he may not be accustomed to
having any caffeine whatsoever and that
might cause a you know
a much worse reaction than what they're
expecting
and yeah i i think that's a really
interesting point i thought the same
thing about how
they never
touch on what what was going on with him
and and when you were talking gil i just
thought about the idea that maybe this
is still from whenever things went bad
before you know what i mean whenever
after he got into that low place after
chuck's death
um but we don't know and they don't then
they made a point of not telling us
and
you're right jim i mean he he's pretty
he's pretty
it's pretty hard to imagine him being
like really
a really despicable husband you know
he's a pretty he's a pretty
straightforward kind of you know
normal guy he doesn't seem all that that
that weird when it comes down to it
so yeah i think that um
i i wonder if they're gonna if we're
gonna see any more of that i really i
don't know i mean it was pretty
effective what we saw
and you know um
i guess more so
yeah it's really hard to to kind of
figure out what they you know what he
would you know what's going to happen to
him i could definitely see him being
collateral damage you know something
happens where
they didn't expect it they thought they
had everything under control and then
you know something goes wrong um
you know there's a popular theory that
he's going to commit suicide that seems
a little bit too much like what happened
to chuck you know i kind of
don't think they'll go down that road
again
if you had to guess um what's going to
happen to howard whenever this plan goes
through what would what would you come
up with and i wanted to say uh thanks to
rod kiefer for the 999 super chat i
appreciate that so jim if you had to gun
to your head what's going to happen to
howard
i don't want to steal too much of gill's
thunder here because over on one take
they laid it out pretty well i think uh
with this judge and everything i've got
a crazy theory though uh
is there any possibility here guys that
he
might not be the one who's the recipient
of whatever
uh chemical the vet gave them
that perhaps
they could dose cliff
and make cliff think that howard somehow
dosed him
hmm
that's it because i noticed there are a
couple of themes in this right it's
called axe and grind uh grind to me says
coffee coffee grounds um
and we see cliff drinking coffee in this
episode some really bad courthouse
coffee uh
it and when jimmy's looking in the
mirror he's looking in the mirror at his
own dilated pupils that just gives me
this theme of like
maybe there's something to
you know howard accidentally
hands him a coffee that has something in
it and he thinks oh he's like
tricked me i i don't know it's it's a
wild out there theory but i think gil
has the actual real theory here well i
think it's as you were talking i was
like there is some genius to that
because
if you get howard to accuse jimmy of
doing all these things behind the scenes
that makes him look paranoid then he
accuses the judge because he sees the
judge in that picture seemingly taking a
bribe from jimmy and then on top of that
he looks at
uh cliff and he's like and this guy
cliff is clearly on drugs look at his
pupils
that would really
make him look pretty bad
could be could be
yeah so it could be so what is this what
is this theory girl
well basically you know we talked before
this that i think they've given us
enough to at least piece together what
we think is their ultimate plan for
d-day
and they knew that howard was going to
be following them at a certain point or
have a pi watching them so they had
jimmy go to a bank and take out twenty
thousand dollars in cash so now howard
is thinking he's going to do something
unscrupulous with that money so they get
a look alike for casemiro the ex-judge
will be overseeing the mediation and
they stage a photo where it looks like
jimmy is handing an envelope to casimiro
so the pi grabs that picture howard
looks at it he's going to put two and
two together and think the judge is
taking a bribe from jimmy that's what
the money was for
so
we
adam and i on over on one take in our
podcast sawcast we've been thinking that
chuck's big downfall was that he started
publicly accusing jimmy of all these
things in the courtroom and it made him
look super paranoid and i started to
wonder if the same thing would happen
with howard and i think that's where
we're going
that they're going that drug they were
testing on jimmy and if you look at all
their post-it notes one of the steps was
drug test i think or test drive
and then the next step said how do we
deliver or something like that so i
think they'll try and find a way to take
to get howard to take the drug and then
when he's all hopped up on those drugs
and he sees the picture of casemiro
he'll go crazy and start accusing jimmy
start accusing the judge everyone's in
on it and that's when
they realize they need to settle this
case and howard can't handle it
yeah and i i thought that that was the
implication and that they will be doing
that
on that call
i mean
do you think that call is part of that
um that jimmy was trying to get the
number for
yeah i figured that call was i i took
that as just
so they could observe what's happening
in the room and make sure that
everything goes as planned that's like
the dial-in number for the meeting
yeah because all the clients are going
to be on that if they want to be so
they're going to their their you know
their their lead uh
you know lead lawyer is going to be
acting like a crazy person throwing
around accusations that obviously can't
be backed up because jimmy like you said
set all that up you know we see him set
that
that photograph up and how you know that
would have probably worked pretty well
if if we you know if we didn't find out
what happened at the end
so yeah i thought that i'm pretty much
on the same page i i think that
even if he
even if he doesn't actually get high and
and and get stark raving mad it'll be
enough for
cliff to see him look like there's
something wrong with him
while he makes these claims because you
know they're they can't
it's they're they're wrong he's being
misled right
[Music]
um let me look at this really quickly uh
pamela phillips thank you for the five
dollars pete gill and mike does anyone
believe me that howard's depressed now
after meeting cheryl yeah i think that
he is uh he's in a lot better shape than
he was in you know the beginning of
season five
but
uh he's still going to the therapist and
um
it would it it's a depressing situation
he might be putting on a good face but
i don't think he's happy living in that
little room with his clothes
and you know um not being able to make
any progress to try to fix things uh
what do you think jim do you think we
got a depressed howard here
uh yeah yeah like you said he's putting
on a good face but
i don't know he's he's a high-strung guy
a high-functioning guy too
but yeah he
can't be happy right now
yeah putting on a good face putting a
good face on things is actually his job
so he's really good at that
gill you have anything that you need to
or you'd like to add to that
just that i completely agree he puts on
a good face pretty much all the time
that we see him and i feel like there
was only one moment where we saw his
true feelings come out which is when he
was talking to his wife about should we
go to this event together and she says
i'll go and he goes that's probably for
the best and for that moment he's
looking away from her and we actually
get to see his face
and he looks pretty depressed in that
moment and he literally is he's saying
the things she wants to hear yeah that's
for the best but you can kind of hear in
his voice and see in his face yeah i
don't think he's too happy right now
yeah and
the other thing i wanted to talk about
was the pi we kind of touched on it
there
i didn't i i there's one thing i didn't
understand about this um
and it kind of goes back to the board a
little bit too because
if you look at it closely
it's possible that they
that jimmy and kim
might have
hired this pi like he might be working
with them did you guys have that
impression based on how things played
out or
is are they just manipulating the
situation knowing that he would get a pi
i feel like it would definitely
explain how they will get the photo to
howard and make him think it's
legitimate because they need him to see
the picture of jimmy meeting with the
judge and he needs to believe it
so if the pi were working with them that
definitely explained how they do it
but i don't know it would feel a little
bit like a cheat to me that they don't
show us how they get howard to hire this
particular pi
because that does feel like a difficult
step in the process
so
i guess i'm on the fence with that i
could see it going one way or the other
yeah you're exactly where i am like uh i
had someone in the comments say well
obviously since
you know jimmy has the photos and he
knows that he's gonna see them then that
confirms but i don't think that does
confirm i mean they could they could
send the the envelope an envelope with
photos from the pi to his office or
something like that and they know that
he would see it you know they but
yeah i don't know like it
that it's an important step in their
their plan
but again you how how would they do that
how would they get him to hire a
particular pi in the first place
yeah i feel
just swapped the envelopes like kim did
with the
mesa verde bank plans
yeah yeah
get huel to bump into somebody and
suddenly howard's holding a different
envelope
yeah
yeah um do you guys have anything else
you want to add on howard before we move
on
nope nothing for me
all right and i just want to get this uh
super chat out of the way real quick
zoom in monkey thank you for the one
pound 79
what do you think the next step for lalo
is um
we're going to talk about lalo later so
i don't want to i don't want to go too
far down that road at the moment but
just
knee-jerk i think he's going to find out
i saw somebody mention in the comments
of my video that
you know casper doesn't know much but
they did transport them to the job site
in a laundry truck to make that look
like it was a real delivery
so there's a possibility that casper i
mean he's gonna torture casper that's
his next step
or or casper's just gonna give up the
information one way or the other he's
not leaving there
without finding out something about what
gus is doing what he's building
you know before i only thought you know
he only has he only knows about they're
building a big hole under the ground
now that i rethink it they did they did
see the laundry they they got delivered
in the truck and that kind of gives them
the name and he could go off of that and
they walked down inside of it so you
know they know that
generally what to look for
um do you guys have anything else that
you want to add really quickly before we
move on to
the next thing
i think all roads lead to the super lab
yeah i i don't i don't know i i think
like i i will talk about it when we get
there and just like two minutes but um
i don't think we even need to see much
more i mean i think that he'll he'll get
that information he'll kill uh casper
because he can't really keep him alive
after he cut his foot off
and then that will be all he you know
that's the only step he really had to
take it to get him back towards
albuquerque and then you know we'll get
into like what he might do after that in
a minute
so like i said they they jump around a
lot in this episode
and um
one of the parts that i found really
funny
personally
was francesca and what she does with
this office and it's just
so it's just so absolutely different
than the one we knew in um
breaking bad and it's funny because it's
kind of connected right that
she's still kind of not the same person
like her demeanor and this decor are
are just completely off for what we
what we see during the breaking bad
timeline and um
you know she's a she's a good character
she's always been there kind of uh you
know
she's there whenever they need her to do
something but i i thought this was you
know a pretty good franchesca episode
all the way around and i'm i'm really
curious to see how this transformation
takes place
it's like her own it's like her own like
you know walter white heisenberg thing
that that's going on there in the
background which i think will make it a
lot more funny whenever we see her when
we re-watch breaking bad later
oh
her turning into the francesca we know
in these scenes like
the guy putting the cigarette out on her
fancy couch the guy yeah turning the
water feature on let's say uh
that that stuff is just killing her it's
going to eat her up and
i i i'm so sad for her but also i love
to see it
yeah
i just thought it was it was hilarious
and i thought you know this was really
it's been happening for the last couple
episodes but we see
bob odenkirk playing the character more
as saul like there's more of a a natural
easing into to the way he played it in
in breaking bad
i don't mind being mistaken for gus
um
the i felt the same way about the way
you said that he's starting to feel more
and more like saul and get really
comfortable in that role and i
especially felt it when he was
pressuring francesca to make that call
and i've been saying it for the last few
episodes but more and more i'm sort of
starting to hate jimmy and kim
it's easy to get wrapped up in the
moment when they're taking down ken for
example at the bar and they get ten
thousand or they get an expensive bottle
of fiero anejo off of him you get swept
up in the moment but to watch them so
deliberately go through this plan when
more and more it becomes clear they
don't need to
even for the original reasons they said
they wanted to do it for the money so
kim can start a practice it's become
clear by the end of this episode they
don't need to do that so i've started to
hate them more and more
and jimmy especially in this moment when
he was kind of his most saul pressuring
francesca to make that call i really
turned on him in that moment
but i loved jim your point about the
turning on the water feature we also i
missed it but adam pointed it out to me
we see the dumpster in the we see the
toilet in the dumpster behind jimmy so
the the toilet humor that motif
definitely continuing even halfway
through the final season
yeah it's almost shocking how unlikable
jimmy was in that then that um
in that call uh
situation with um
francesca
you know it it didn't
the the the traces of the things you
like about the character just seem to be
absent and um it was a pretty good
i thought they put that together pretty
well and just a reminder because you
know we've been watching
jimmy for for uh you know so many
seasons now you kind of forget
how um
kind of callous
he played him in the other series and
you know the the call i guess that's
really the last thing that happens with
her here but
um
yeah it's a slippery slope right and
she's she's in his orbit and it's going
to take her down
and
you know like you said the watching the
guy put the cigarette out and
just day in and day out just that's
that's her life for the next uh four
years until we see her again so
lots of fun there
um yeah and we touched on it a bit but
we can move on and talk about mike a
little bit one of the things that i i
thought was was kind of strange or not
really strange but it just hit me i
guess when i was watching this is that
mike still answers to tyrus in this
series um you know we kind of saw tyrus
pull a gun on him
in episode
two or in and three i guess and
uh it's kind of strange because
in breaking bad you know mike was always
the top guy right you know that was the
impression everybody else answered to
him
so it was kind of it was kind of neat to
see that that uh flipped around
and you know the the the reveal that
he's he's pulling you know obviously
they got a lot of stuff going on and
he's pulling resources to uh take care
of his family
he's actually taking people off of his
own duties so that there's nobody
watching his house
just so he can keep a pretty i mean he
has the house next door he has security
cameras he's got them locked down over
there like nobody's getting close to
them
and um you know i just thought it was
like i said at first it felt like it was
out of place it was sort of like do we
really need to do this
there's a gus there's no gus at all
which i guess might be related to the
fact that um john carlo was directing
and um you know i think it's
we i know we saw kim she had quite a few
scenes in ray seahorn's episode but i
think it you know if you had your if you
had your choice if you if you were going
to direct you wouldn't want to act too
much in the episode that you're working
on so you can just focus on that
and so yeah i just thought maybe that
was the thing they're trying to keep a
thread to the gut storyline in there and
then um
you know it's just a it was just a like
a warm scene and it it's got that
underlying
i know what's going to happen here so it
really kind of sucks thing going on but
um
how did you how did you i mean what did
you guys think about this did you think
that it was superfluous did it was it
necessary
uh or
what were your impressions
uh no i i liked it um
i think like you said it's a warm scene
it's it's a
it's a heartfelt moment before we get to
what's sure to be a tragic uh end for
probably several people
either next episode or going into the
last half of the season
uh yeah and mike is one of the
characters that i care about you know i
i know look he's not going to make it
all the way out but
you wanted to get as far as as he can
with as much uh humanity and happiness
as possible i think scenes like this go
a pretty long way for that
yeah jim i was thinking the same thing i
was wondering what
knowing that mike is going to die and
breaking bad what could make me feel a
little happier for the mike character
and
the one thing is he gets to spend more
time with his family than we knew by the
time we get to breaking bad and what
sucks so much is that we know he has a
limited amount of time left with them
and he can't get close to them
it's uh and i feel like there's one
trick this show has gone back to and
breaking bad
a couple of times walter white calling
his family having something he wants to
say and he can't say it right he has to
pretend to be really gruff
and make sure everyone knows that his
wife had nothing to do with anything
same thing with nacho he wants to call
his dad and say bye and he can't say it
and then here mike is talking to his
family and he has to treat it like a
normal call he can't let them know that
he's so desperate to see them and that
things are pretty tough for him right
now and those scenes are always hard to
watch
so i want to see what happens in the
next few episodes and in context did
this scene serve more of a purpose than
just it's a warm scene it's kind of
catching up on mike's situation
but just viscerally the scene definitely
worked for me yeah i think that it felt
like a set up for a showdown with wallow
did you guys pick up on that or were you
thinking that
it could be though the the
scene we see with gus last episode makes
me think the showdown will probably be
between them
uh instead of yeah
so like the final showdown yeah yeah
yeah
though pete one thing you said that
triggered a thought for me
is that by the time we get to breaking
bad it definitely seems like mike is
higher on the totem pole and gus's
organization
and that makes me wonder if he'll be
pretty pivotal in resolving the lalo
situation somehow maybe we even see the
showdown in the meth lab next week but
it doesn't go as planned and the chase
continues
so gus isn't able to handle it himself
and mike is the one that's able to
finally resolve things
yeah that's an interesting idea because
i i don't think they're going to resolve
that
next week
you know i think that there's going to i
think that we'll you know we'll talk
about this in a minute but i think that
they will actually
get to the end of the howard thing and
like i said it may end in a a
cliffhanger where you don't see the
aftermath but i i don't think that we're
going to see any more
of of that any you know being pursued
after the break um
but which makes me think that they will
that lalo still will be out there um
and yeah i you know that's a good idea
that that whatever happens in these next
few episodes is what makes what what
elevates mike to his his position um
yeah that's definitely interesting
and you know we were talking about it
being warm and we talking about it you
know
possibly uh setting things up for for
what he's gonna have to face and
it's it's terribly you know it it's it's
not it you don't like it's the way that
it works is you're there in that moment
with those characters
but that thing is always gnawing at the
back of your head because
you know
or uh walter's thing was always lying to
himself telling himself that he was
doing it for his family and then in this
in bcs we saw that you know like nacho
he he made his sacrifice for his father
he really did that
and mike is you know he's the opposite
of walter in that way he really is doing
it for his family
you know if it wasn't for them he'd be
okay
working in the uh you know working in
the the parking lot and going home and
drinking pap's blue ribbon and watching
old movies on tcm or whatever he does
you know what i mean he's like he's a
pretty simple guy in retirement but
he's in all of this because he's one he
wants to take care of of his
granddaughter so
yeah that's a pretty good that's a
pretty good place i think to move on
from him
and
lalo he's still in germany
he's uh he's the star of a
he starts out in this one as kind of
like the star of a horror movie whenever
he shows up at at casper's place casper
was the was the guy he he was always
noticeable in the background he didn't
do much in in in that story that kind of
all focused on kai
as being the problematic one but before
he went back to germany he did
deliver that line to mike saying you
know verner was worth 50 of you and
mike couldn't even really dispute that
you know he understood where he's coming
from
as opposed to whenever kai said
something to him he punched him in the
face so you know he was a pretty solid
dude uh we didn't know a lot about him
he apparently lives in the middle of
nowhere now and he was chopping wood he
had the unfortunate timing of chopping
wood with an axe whenever
this mysterious mexican man
emerges from the forest
which is a pretty funny setup when you
think about it um
dapper looking uh you know he he doesn't
completely look out out of place but
obviously casper's been a little bit
worried that you know something might
happen as as a result of what they did
there since verner died and all that
and um
he decides to run and that wasn't really
you know that was kind of a good plan
but he doesn't follow through when the
time comes he decides to try to hit him
with the back of the axe and figure out
who he is rather than just murdering him
which you know
not everyone's a killer and
you know that you can kind of see why he
might do that
you know rather than you know he'd have
to there's a lot of there's
there's a point of no return in that if
you do hit him with the axe um
but yeah it all goes very badly for him
and it was pretty intense like one of
the things that stood out to me a lot
was
how much tony dalton sold the the fact
that he had been hit in the back with an
axe um
the way he was struggling to breathe and
get through that dialogue it was it was
pretty convincing
and i loved how they had the little
sneak you know i'm like what is he
holding behind the card and then right
as i figure it out the slash happens and
you know casper loses a foot there
so what were your what were your
impressions of lalo's big trip to the
middle of nowhere
jim you want to go first oh yeah uh i
was just super impressed that casper
could get the drop on lalo i've i i've
seen him
face down
a whole armed squad of hitmen uh
assassins
uh
not not realizing they were there until
it should have been too late and take
them all out uh
i was very surprised that casper was
able to
get the drop on him in the first place
but you're right like he he doesn't
really know who
who he's dealing with right both how
dangerous this man is
and also
is is he dangerous you know is this
someone i should hit with an axe let
alone
uh front the front side of the axe right
like
he doesn't know so i don't blame him too
much for uh
losing the advantage there but yeah i i
really enjoyed this scene this this
feels very lollow to me
yeah
it's a big decision hitting someone with
an axe i mean you know i saw a lot of
people complaining about this about how
oh
how are you going to hit somebody with i
mean
how are you going to hit somebody with
the front of the max you know i mean
it's a big step in your life things
change after you go through with that
sorry gil i didn't mean to cut you off
oh no it's all good yeah i just agreed
with all of the above uh pete the same
thing that stuck out to you stuck out to
me just the way that he sold
that he'd been hit
it sounded so real and we've never
really seen lalo that i can think of in
a position where someone has truly
bested him in that moment
um
but i had a feeling lala always has
something up his sleeve so as soon as
you see that razor i was like ah damn it
and the same thing you said it's easy
for us as viewers we know who lalo is
this guy doesn't you know i want to yell
at casper if you're going to look at
that card maybe tell him to put it on
the ground slide it over to you don't
stick your face that close to lalo
uh so it was an intense scene
and i just feel bad for anybody in
lalo's path
yeah
rip casper i mean he he's definitely
dead now we're agreed on that
oh yeah yep i think so
no way that lalo can let him survive
after the old
foot cut uh maneuver surprised how
grizzly that foot chop was too they
showed up close
yeah yeah i didn't have a screenshot of
that one but yeah his foot's just laying
next to next to his uh
soon to be bleeding out body
i also love the uh the color filtering
by the way it's just so it's so
noticeable i wanted to point it out
anytime we cut to mexico there's sort of
a yellow hue
and then in this scene there was kind of
a bluish hue so i knew we're either not
in america or we're in a flashback and
then confirmed germany is blue
so that's kind of the color coding that
may not be relevant as the season goes
on because i think i'm with you pete
that kind of the next step
is come back to albuquerque
yeah and man there's so many questions
about how that's gonna go down i mean if
they've done if they've not done
anything in the last couple of episodes
on gus it's they've showed us that he is
on the lookout for any lalo sightings
anywhere in the in the city and um
there's a lot of potential for some
interesting uh maneuvering going on
there i mean you you tend to think that
he might have to go and
reach out to his lawyer
saul goodman but um
with how crazy everything is in their
story right now
with kim who we're going to talk about
in one second um it's hard to it's hard
to imagine
how he's going to be able to get close
to gus
except for the fact that gus you know
probably will try to set a trap
you know do you guys have anything else
you want to add to lala before we move
on
now just that my
gut agree when you said he's probably
going to go to his lawyer or that's kind
of what we tend to think
that is also where my head goes because
he's going to
how does he get close to gus
well
maybe he starts with saul and
and or kim and works from there
yeah i mean if you're that kind of guy
that's what you do right you you you
have
you can
once someone helps you then you can just
basically scare them into doing that for
the rest of their lives
i think kim talked him down at the end
of what was the last season but i don't
i don't know that she made it seem like
he was innocent
it's just
it was not worth the hassle or whatever
um for la la you know so i still think
lalo has an idea that jimmy might have
been involved in
what went down
yeah that'll be interesting it'll be
nice to see
uh it'll be nice to see the german
excursion come to an end and um
see things get closer
and i do agree jim that
you know it's probably the the showdown
the way it's set up i mean gus is not
going to believe lalo's dead unless
he he sees lalo dead
and and he kind of needs to do that for
his story to make sense
and everything else that happens in the
cartel to make sense in breaking bad
but i you know i imagine there's going
to be a little bit of cat and mouse
between him and mike and
we'll uh i got a couple of super chats
here and then we'll move on and talk
about kim because yeah that's going to
what happens there is going to be pretty
important for what gus finds when he
gets there
so we have uh
big mac 076
thank you for the 499. is it possible
howard's pi is actually working for kim
and jimmy
only thinking this because jimmy has the
photos in his car at the end of the
episode
we touched on this earlier uh maybe you
showed up a little bit later uh but yeah
we're we're not 100 clear um
the part that's hard to understand if
that's true is how did they get howard
to pick him um you know he he went out
to hire a pi did did this guy show up at
his door and say hey you need a pi for
something i'm around and give him his
card
you know it none of it really makes all
that much sense when i think it through
but i do think there's a possibility
but there's you know then also think
about the fact that that if they know he
has a pi which they do then they can
kind of manipulate things to make howard
believe that he's getting something from
the pi when he's really getting it from
them
and i think one point of clarification
in this person's question he says that
jimmy has the photos in his car in case
it's not clear
those are different photos from the ones
the pi had because the photos that jimmy
has
are photos of the casimiro body double
with jimmy
so
that doesn't mean they're definitely not
working with the pi but just to be clear
that they want to get those photos to
howard so he believes the judge is
working with jimmy yeah that goes back
to what i was saying about that comment
that i had too uh they you know they're
saying that
jimmy saw the photos jimmy took the
photos that he wants for the plant you
know what i mean
that's what that's what they were doing
they were setting things up inside um
his office with the with the film
students to take these pictures that are
gonna you know be important
so of course he saw those ones
and we have one from reeks muhammad
thank you for the 4.99
i noticed they still haven't mentioned
or shown nachos dad your thoughts
well this is something we've talked
about before on here
actually the three of us because uh jim
was on the nacho episode too uh my my
thinking is that we may not see any more
of of nachos dad i feel like that there
was a conclusion to his story
um
jim have you changed your mind on that
or where were you at whenever we we were
talking about this last
yeah that conversation they had on the
phone really felt final to me so i i
think he's probably gone
yeah you you were under the impression
that they might kill him though now that
i remember back to that um how do you
feel about that now it would it would be
the extra gut punch that i'm always
looking for in the show certainly like i
said uh but
i don't know i don't really need it i
feel like there are going to be some gut
punches to come in some of the main
story lines with characters who are
still alive
uh so nah nah i'm good
yeah i i think that's a good point i
don't think they're starved for
big things to happen
um
and it's a little tricky you know we
talked about this at the time i i mean
you have mike he he doesn't like the
fact of the idea of someone not getting
closure
but his job kind of requires it here
you know like he can't really he can't
really tell
nacho's dad what really happened
and i i just never really thought that i
thought the way that they set up the
story you know it was
it was such a it was such a a poignant
sacrifice
that i didn't think that we were really
supposed to
take away from that that oh maybe he he
maybe by telling hector he put him in
the chair that he put his father
in
danger you know i mean and
you know you can disagree with that but
i just that wasn't my impression in the
moment my impression was that he he did
his plan
he got to go out on his own terms and
throw that little jab in on the way out
and still kind of keep his end of the
deal and i think that the cartel would
keep the salamancas to that on some
level and that's what you know then you
have mike but
i don't expect that we're gonna see them
gil did you have anything else you
wanted to add to that
just that the question has come up so
many times that in the episode last
night
when mike was drawing that hard line of
we're not taking any resources away from
that house for a second i thought are
they gonna show that mike is monitoring
nacho's dad to make sure he's safe and
then of course
only took a second to realize there's a
couple people in his life that he cares
about pretty dearly and that's who he's
talking about
but uh yeah i 100 agree with everything
you said i feel like we're done with it
maybe not but to me it feels like the
book is closed
yeah and haley thank you for the two
dollars she says how do you guys think
jimmy finds out about
or finds out lola was alive um
i think lala's gonna come to him
that's my that's my guess i don't think
he would otherwise um
anybody have an alternate idea there
i mean we just sort of talked about this
like i think
he could find out who else could even
find out from mike i mean why would that
jim he well he told
okay
back up i forgot all about the fact that
he told that mike told kim already um
okay so
something could happen and kim could
tell him
what do you got what do you guys think
what's more likely kim's going to tell
him or lala's going to show up at his
front door
no i think you're right lalo is probably
going to come knocking uh
and that's
and then the question is like will kim
fess up and say hey i knew about this
um yeah that's another point of
contention there yeah sleeping dog lie i
don't know
yep yeah i think
lala showing up feels more right to me
because it does feel like kim has made
the decision not to tell jimmy so the
only way she'd change her mind is if
she's backed into the corner back into a
corner and needs to tell him and it's
just hard for me to picture what would
that scenario be
like lala's coming after them and she
has to tell him so they can run
but it just feels like how would she
know that lala's coming after them and
not jimmy so yeah to me it feels like
that's more likely sorry what was that
jim could mike tell her like warn her
you know
his eyes all over the place following
her
could be that he finds out lala's coming
after her warns her and she has to tell
jimmy
yeah that's that's a that's a good point
in any way in any case it sounds like we
all feel like if it happens it'll either
be lalo showing up or a warning like an
imminent warning that he's about to show
up
so she won't tell him to the last
possible second
yeah lala makes stuff happen you know
what i mean like that's his he's a he's
a uh an agent of change so
i think that he'll he'll be
stirring up quite a few different things
whenever he makes it to albuquerque
craig otto thank you for the five
dollars that's awesome uh and we have
one more here
thomas bark it looks like 20
swedish kroners maybe or something like
that i don't know
do you think we'll have a full episode
with gene absolutely i think we might
have more than one
what do you think gail
100 agreed yeah i think
at least a whole episode
but i think very good chance that we'll
get more than that
jim
yeah i hope so
yeah i think whenever you don't have the
uh the the opening teaser that means
that
you're saving it up
and you're going to i mean obviously
they're going to resolve that story and
there's a lot to resolve and um yeah i'm
under the impression that at least one
if not two or
you know maybe it'll be
spread out over a few that is and
there's some uh breaking bad stuff mixed
in there at the same time breaking bad
timeline stuff and um
yeah i think that i would be pretty
pretty disappointed if we didn't have at
least one whole gene there's no more
gene scenes we've seen the last of them
they're just going to leave that as a
open thread
he just the last scene is him walking
across the parking lot shooting uh jeff
execution style and it cuts to black
that's it
wow
it'd be powerful huh
all right so now now we're at the uh now
we're at after um 52 minutes we've made
it back we got everything else down to
kim
and i just noticed that we went over a
thousand for for people here so that's
awesome welcome everyone
glad to see you all join us um i got one
more uh super chat that just popped up
so hold on one second jack larkin thank
you for the 499. if the pi isn't working
with jimmy kim
then how did they recreate the style of
the pi's photos
also wouldn't the pi notice them doing
the photo shoot that's actually a good
point that that doesn't really make
sense he's being watched and and i
thought the same thing about it when
they went and sat outside of hhm in this
episode those were two things that kind
of bothered me a little bit
i don't usually get too
uh you know i have a pretty high
tolerance for some things when it comes
to
whatever but those two things like we're
supposed to believe that this guy is
watching jimmy 24 hours a day but yet
he's able to do that right out in front
of his office i mean the photo
definitely takes place right in front of
the off like at his door
and and yeah they go to hhm and they
look at it from the outside which made
for a good scene you know like you
mentioned um i can't remember which one
of you mentioned it but you know the
kind of calm before the storm
um
but yeah wouldn't he have seen them do
that and that wouldn't that kind of set
off some red flags but
one answer might be that yeah that he's
working for them the whole time and all
of what he's showing howard is
um
staged
but i don't know the style of the fiat
uh pi's photos i think they're pretty
standard telephoto lens black and white
and they kind of showed the um
the the guy from the the film student
he looked like he went and got a
specific
uh you know mirror camera slr or
whatever and um
he would probably since he's a student
he probably wouldn't know how to do you
know if he showed him a photo or
whatever then he probably could do that
you guys have anything you want to add
to
this i think the style of the photos
doesn't sell me as much that to me feels
like
they if they know they're being followed
there's a way for them to figure out
like you said they're pretty standard
photos
but what is turning me around to
thinking maybe the pi is working for
them is your point about them going to
hhm that that kind of rubbed me the
wrong way a little bit in the episode
two because that feels so dangerous if
anybody sees them there or if howard
gets any idea that they were there it
feels like such a dead giveaway
and if they knew the pi was working for
them that would of course make them feel
totally comfortable doing that
so that's a good point i'm starting to
warm up to the idea
yeah i mean they're you know they i
understand why they would get a kick out
of sitting there and and sort of having
their glass of wine and enjoying the
moment but yeah
you know i'm not not to
beat a dead horse you got anything on
that jim
i mean if you've seen any noir movie you
could probably duplicate these photos i
you know you see every 1940s uh film
but yeah no that's it's wild it's risky
but i mean these are risk takers right i
feel like they're not
so conservative um that they would be
worried about getting caught here they'd
be more the feeling the thrill of
sitting outside hhm the night before
yeah and we got one more here
craig otto thank you for the five
dollars do you all think nachos stole
gus's revenge i love revisiting all the
bb gus hector scenes and knowing nacho
is there too um i don't think he stole
his revenge uh you know i think
i think gus did a pretty good job of
i mean he he
hector was on his way to recovery and
and gus stopped it
so even though
um
nacho played a part in that getting
putting him in that in that chair uh gus
made sure it happened so he he's got a
hand in that i think that there's some
satisfaction in that for him
and yeah it will be um interesting to
re-watch breaking bad and think about
that when we see hector now that you
know nacho was behind that that was
never there before
you guys got anything that you want to
add on this
uh they dealt a little bit with it i
remember a conversation between
uh you know when you saw mike uh
imploring gus to sort of let nacho out
of his hold i think a lot of the reason
he didn't is because he wanted to punish
him a bit for
attempting to take hector's life
um you know he wanted to do that and if
i recall there's a scene in like the the
escalade or whatever where they're
sitting there talking about
pretty much exactly that um so yeah i
think there was an element of that
where like gus felt
that this was his i i say when
he's had enough for when i i say how he
suffers or how he dies
yeah
yeah and um i'm sorry i was looking at
the at the chat here and um
this character this uh michael kb was
asking is there a thread for prosecutors
to pull at given that kim visited lalo
in jail i'd be on a visitor log
why would she visit a normal client um
i guess that kind of ties back into what
we were saying about the uh
you know about how how will he find out
and what is their uh exposure there and
um yeah we talked about this before in
the past but
though she would definitely be they
would be able to find that out
they kind of dropped the susan erickson
thread um that hasn't really come back
up do you think there's going to be
anything
i mean everything feels like we're
getting ready to talk about kim right
now and everything feels like it's
pointing to this moment and all of that
just doesn't really seem all that
necessary to me right now
what do you guys agree disagree
yeah
sorry gil go ahead
i'm just going to say i i do think
that's an open thread that we're going
to come back to at some point
i don't know how much of a role that
particular fact is going to play that
kim visited lalo in jail but i do think
it would seem natural for it to come up
if there's another conversation with
erickson and you know she she tried
going through kim to get to jimmy and
say i think he's a good guy underneath
and that didn't work so maybe the next
time she'll try to pull kim into it as
well and say i know you visited him
maybe you're involved too now it's hard
to read too much into all she knows is
that she visited him and if jimmy wants
to protect kim he could pretty easily
say
she was worried about me she went to go
see him but she has nothing to do with
whatever we were up to
so
i do think it's an open thread we'll
come back to i just don't know how
important that visit will be
yeah and so
now we let's move on to kim um
we see her there she's not quite got the
ponytail but she's starting to
starting to move in that direction
um she gets caught for it's a flashback
it's back to nebraska we're back in
the 80s
and she gets caught
shoplifting and her mom comes in
and rescues her and they get to
she kind of i thought one thing that
stood out to me here whenever she was
talking to her like when she was uh you
know when she was kind of performatively
chewing her out it reminded me of some
of those exchanges where we saw kim do
that with uh chuck and um
she did it with howard but she was she
was coming from like
a genuine place when she did that but
also and with lalo you know what i mean
um
interesting i mean
this is a side of kim we kind of all
assumed was there that you know that she
took risks you know that with that that
maybe she was
into some kind of um
you know some kind of uh slippery
behavior before she met jimmy
and you know when you when you see her
mother here and you see that she's ready
to to
to
con her way out of this you know it kind
of i kind of felt like okay
now i see that why she thinks jimmy is
you know why she's not put off by that
what were your what were your takes on
on
this uh just just the part where we're
talking you know where she's in the
where she's been caught for shoplifting
in that exchange gail
uh
yeah i keep any time we see a little
glimpse into kim or jimmy's childhood
i think about positive and negative
reinforcement so here
where
her mom is sort of warmed towards her as
a result of her shoplifting i didn't
think you had it in you she's very
complimentary
so
i assume this is not an isolated
incident we're seeing a sort of example
of the way her life was back then
so to me that's positive reinforcement
if you scam if you steal
that's good
and a few people pointed it out i didn't
catch it on my first watch through but
the earrings that her mother gives her
in the scene are the same earrings that
kim wears to this day
so clearly it was an important moment
for her
and
i think to your point we a lot of us
have wondered if this sort of slip and
kimi or giselle side has been there
longer than we realized
and i think this makes it clear that it
has been perhaps her mother fostered it
with that positive reinforcement
and kind of like marco's ring that jimmy
wears it's something that she thinks
about you know that's why she keeps
those earrings
yeah i mean the earrings are fascinating
i noticed that right away and it's weird
because i'm not the kind of person
that's really
that perceptive when it comes to
little details in the way that the you
know that they costume and things like
that
but she wears them she doesn't wear them
all the time but she wears them so often
that they were recognizable to me right
whenever i saw them and
and yeah it is it's sort of like one of
those things like what i don't have
anything from that time of my life that
i would still be carrying around you
know what is she maybe
15 or
14 i don't know you know what i mean
like this is a time where you're in
seventh grade or something you don't you
don't carry that stuff around with you
like she's she wears these uh she wore
these i went and looked at their first
scam
with ken wins and she's definitely
wearing them in that which makes me
believe that she she pulls them out on
special occasions
um
and and it's fascinating what you're
saying there about positive
reinforcement because they set this up
with the other flashback which shows us
that
she kind of doesn't like her mom in a
lot of ways too you know what i mean so
she's getting mixed signals and and the
whole situation like here being in this
room
is hard you know being growing up being
a teenager is very difficult and you're
just getting all this weird mixed
signals from everywhere
and uh yeah at the end of the day she
does get away with it her mom is
is backing her up because she she didn't
know she had it in her i saw some people
say that they thought that they were
working together like this was a scam
like i i don't think that's the case um
i didn't have that takeaway i thought
that
she did actually get in trouble her mom
came in and then she tried to be the
cool mom by getting her out of it and
stealing them too
and you know i think maybe you know you
could make an argument that that kim as
a teenager was acting out she wanted to
have her mother's attention and then she
got the wrong kind of attention
but at the end of the day she got what
she wanted she got the thing that you
know she was trying to steal
so jim where are you at on on this whole
locked in the back room kind of
situation and what how that plays out
uh i really like this scene i think it
it is kind of an example of what the
creators of breaking bad and the show do
so well uh it's
one of the reasons that i love episodes
of breaking bad like the fly and i get a
lot of [ __ ] for that but
uh one of the reasons i like it is
because it's a character study and it's
complex right it's
it's and these characters one of the
things they do so well is tell you
that yes they have
feelings but they're not like tracking a
single line from here to there it's
very messy as as real people are
i think you look at kim in these early
scenes
these two flashbacks we've had of her so
far and you see in the one flashback
she's very angry at her mother for her
behavior right and then you see this
flashback and she gets that positive
reinforcement you're talking about
and we know that we see those earrings
later and they mean something to her her
mother was important to her in some way
and so it's not all
anger that she's feeling toward her
mother there's a lot of sentimentality
there
and i think it's a one of the reasons
why she latches on to jimmy because she
feels
some strange like
kind of postponed stockholm syndrome
from her mother or something like like
she was forced to have this mother who
was kind of a train wreck
but it made her who she is and now she
looks back i i don't know you guys but
like as i get older i notice
boy there are so many things about my
parents that i'm recontextualizing and
seeing in myself
and i don't look those that even even
the things that i'm like man
you know this is a thing about myself
that i wish i could change or something
i don't look at those and go
boy i'm angry my parents for giving me
that i'm i'm kind of looking back fondly
at
what my parents you know how the
influence they had on me so i i see that
happening with kim in these scenes and
it's just so complex so rich and just
feels so real to me
yeah and there's that whole thing of not
knowing and just that
you know like this is this is a this is
a serious drip feed of like
getting just the smallest
like bits of information about her past
and then seeing it like
i i really for one thing i just have to
say that the the casting in this is is
pretty
amazing like the both actors do a great
job of
making me think that this is actually a
young kim and her mother you know
someone like they're not related or
anything like that but they feel like
they they are a mother and a daughter
and that this is you know
the person that will grow up to be kim
and uh you know 30 years or whatever
and you know i really like the the way
that she when she's walking out
and she's still kind of like thinking
about what happened and she reaches out
for her mother's hand and you see your
mother
kind of
like yeah okay this worked you know what
i mean like i
now now she you know now she sees that
i'm i'm i'm
who she you know so that i'm not as bad
as she thinks i am or her or whatever's
going through her head and you know
there's that bit of not knowing there
what what's really going on and like you
said jim it's very
very human it's very
uh you know like complex in the way that
actual people are rather than than
characters on tv um
so yeah i think that this was
it was just it was just uh i was hoping
that we were going to get something like
this i kind of thought that we might and
i think it really delivered
jim one thing you said i really liked is
you're only now starting to realize and
see some of those things and you connect
the dots and see oh that might have come
from my parents and i think part of what
makes these characters so messy and so
true to life is that we're speculating
on why they act a certain way and if you
were to ask them why i don't know that
they would have the answer
like you they may only realize it down
the road and start to make the
connections and that feels very genuine
we're in real life i think there might
be certain things you've done in your
life or any one of us where we wonder
why did i do that why did i make that
decision
uh so i think that's that's a great
point
um i i want to i had a super chat here i
wanted to touch on really quick um
because about kim
tj t magic infinity thank you for the
499 do you think it's likely that kim
dies in the show gets caught
and goes to jail
or or ultimately goes on the run from
either the law or lalo
one of the things that i have loved
about the
kim character
and one of the things i'm kind of having
trouble with after this episode is you
know like i said the not knowing what
was going to happen and the way that
everything was on the table it feels
like those choices are getting narrowed
down now and when i thought about this
it's always been really hard to
speculate
and um
you know primarily because you don't
want anything bad to happen to her or at
least before you didn't want anything
bad to happen to her now it's a little
bit more
you know justifiable maybe
but um
i kind of leaned towards her being in
jail because of that phone call and and
just sort of it it gave them a way to
bring her back
or have her still be out there still be
a part of jimmy's life but just
separated in a way that there was
nothing they could do about it um
gil what do you got as far as does she
die does she get caught go to jail or go
on the run
i don't think she dies uh i i feel like
a
gene and kim reunion has so much
dramatic potential
that i really want to see it
um so hoping for that i feel like she
won't die and how do they get separated
but still want to see each other again
in the future
jail might explain that so
i say this every time if you ask me
again in 10 minutes i'll have an
entirely different prediction so for
this current moment jail sounds good to
me
jim
i like not knowing i like yeah
i really do um
yeah man i i just want to wait and see
honestly i don't have any great theories
because i just don't feel like we have
the info there yet
yeah let the mystery be i mean you know
i i have i you know a lot of times
people want to um
want to speculate and i completely
understand and stand that especially
whenever there you know certain kinds of
tv shows really lend themselves to it
but i feel like better call saul is one
that it just
i'm just i trust that whatever they
decide it's going to be pretty good and
um i find myself a lot more thinking
about what's going on in the in the
characters you know what what what's
driving them to to make their decisions
rather than like plot wise what what
what's going to happen next
the one point pete i want to make is
that i i 100 agree with that and this
season's a little weird and that i feel
like the show is more than usual kind of
demanding that we speculate literally
showing us post-it notes with little
symbols on them that if you look at them
and think about it
you might be able to piece together
what's going to happen or they show gus
do something in the super lab we don't
know what he's doing you know you can
kind of come up with some theories
so it's it's odd that i'm like you where
i'm much more interested in what's
happening with the characters right now
than i am and trying to kind of predict
where things are going to go uh but it's
been a weird season you know all going
all the way back to when jimmy and kim
are discussing the plan and we don't get
to hear it very purposely withholding
that information from us so when this
all wraps up i'll be really curious to
look back at the season in full context
and say why did they make that choice
and did it ultimately work
but as you were talking it just made me
think of that
well that's because usually the scams
play out in the course of an episode
right so we get the the setup and the
resolution all in one uh they've really
teased that out for us yeah it's a good
point that's a good point
yeah i was talking about that last week
in the stream like it was really
bothering me last week it was like
they're keeping us behind them and i
don't i'm not used to this feeling in
this in this situation um
yeah i
i i think they are kind of demanding it
i didn't really think about it in that
way and and it makes me wonder if it's
because that it
in in a way they want to they want us to
i mean i i don't see a i mean we'll talk
about this i guess in a little bit more
when we get to the end of kim but i i
don't see a big twist coming
it's not that kind of show you know
maybe that they're maybe they're leaning
into the the mystery now
because uh you know they want us to
to not to not think too hard about what
was actually going to happen in this
next episode
um
whisper gaming thank you for the 9.99
kid kim was shocked and dropped her
mom's hand in the same way adult kim was
shocked and dropped jimmy's arm at the
end of season 4.
um
either one of you got something on this
is that the episode where he says that
he's gonna be saul goodman now
yeah i presume that's what she's talk or
what they're talking about there
i'm not really sure
exactly when
kid kim drops her mom you know drops her
mom's hand
yeah i don't remember her i i remember
her grabbing her hand
yeah that's the part i remember too yeah
i guess at minimum whisper gaming is
drawing a connection between kim was
definitely surprised by her mother's
reaction she wasn't expecting her mother
to be so supportive of her shoplifting
and kim was similarly surprised
that after the hearing it turns out
jimmy wasn't actually showing remorse
uh over what happened with chuck and
everything it was all a show for
everyone in the courtroom
which i guess is actually another
similarity where in both cases she finds
out oh what just happened it was
disingenuous my mom was putting on a
show for this guy
you know season four jimmy was putting
on a show for the hearing so
maybe that's where she started to learn
about putting on a show you know like
you mentioned before the way she did
with lalo
and the way she has with chuck a couple
of times
yeah that's a great connection because
um
you know the the she she was she
i mean at the end of season four that
was like one of the harshest um
that's that's when you were sort of peak
like
how is jimmy gonna ruin this woman's
life you know
because she bought into it i mean we all
did everyone watching we were all there
with her as he's as he's becoming human
right as he's as he's he's going in the
wrong direction he's not becoming saul
he's becoming
the best version of jimmy and it was all
completely
uh
put on
and and yeah i think there's a
similarity to what happens here with her
mother i do kind of i i do kind of
wonder if if it's not a little bit of
disappointment because you know i i when
i think about like what her mother was
like in the first one
i think about a kid who wants their
mother to be somebody different and show
up and so whenever she comes here
there might have been a part of her that
enjoyed that her mother was actually
concerned
you know obviously she feels like she
doesn't care about her and it turns out
that it was a big you know it was just a
big show to get her out of there without
paying the 35
you know
yeah it's interesting it's an
interesting connection mm-hmm we haven't
really talked about why she did this in
the first place uh why she would shout
i i mean it could just be you know
generally a teenager acting out but do
you have any insight into
maybe what what was the cause of this in
the first place
i mean it's hard like i said i i i do
like the idea that she you know she's
acting out because of her situation at
home and she wants some attention
we don't really we don't really know
enough about like
i mean obviously they were poor if what
she told aker was was accurate um that
seems to be true that they were losing
their they were like homeless at times
because they couldn't pay the rent
um
so
yeah what are your thoughts on i mean do
you have a do you have something that
that that you're thinking about
not in particular other than you know
she wanted this pair of earrings and a
her mother was not around to give it to
her uh to to buy them for her or
i don't know she has an allowance
apparently
maybe
did it was kim rolling her eyes when she
said oh yeah well that's right sure
what's that never heard
yeah
oh man i don't know we just don't know
but you know she because it was all
performance but
she might have an allowance
i uh so a couple of hours ago i don't
know if i should it's a little silly but
i googled what makes a kid act out
and one of the top three reasons was for
attention and when i read that i was
like i do kind of like that idea that
she was looking almost she wanted her
mom to be the sort of mom she wanted the
last time we saw her she was drinking
she was late to pick her up so she
wanted to see something
you know you expect to be punished when
you do something wrong that would be the
typical sort of mom we all imagine and
maybe that's what she wanted so she did
something that she thought would draw
her mother's ire and she ended up not
getting it
so definitely i'm still chewing on this
scene but
that's a read that currently sits kind
of
right with me
yeah and they kind of mention it here
that you know you're talking about
positive reinforcement
her mom says she's a straight a student
i believe that's probably true right
and it doesn't sound like she's getting
any positive reinforcement for that you
know she's just sort of like yeah that's
what kim does that's what she always
does she's she's the responsible one she
does well
so acting out in that context makes a
lot of sense to me
right
we got a couple other ones here about
kim so let's let's go through a bit
um
let's see craig otto thank you for the
five dollars love all your channels as
the two months ago very grateful to
finally discover you all as well as
vivid kiwi
is a four-person chat too much for the
finale um i know i think we'll we'll
definitely be um
kiwi will definitely be coming back um
i think four is kind of our
is kind of the limit i don't think we'll
we'll go beyond four but i think four
could work um we it's a little bit
difficult because we're all busy the day
before because we're all working on
content and then we you know we could
sort of do this so
we'll whenever the big episodes come
we'll do some planning and yeah you i
think you'll be happy with the lineup
that we get get going
um what else we got here
well there's a couple more i missed um
anna thank you for the two dollars i
appreciate that
the omen i'm not buying the foundation
meeting i think it was a play to get kim
in some sort of ambush
blessing in disguise she took the right
road
hmm
this occurred to me never um
this is the first time thinking of it
had anybody else considered this
no he's saying about chuck you know he's
saying about for cliff the meeting that
he set up that that was all
that wasn't a real thing the the
foundation wasn't moving to the
southwest that was all just a ploy to
get her to come to santa fe
to i don't know do an intervention or or
do something along those lines
yeah that feels like a little bit too
twisty for me like you said earlier pete
the show doesn't usually do the big
twist they definitely have done twists
in breaking bad and in this show but
this feels a little bit
there's a lot is a lot that would have
had to have happened that we didn't see
so much that this doesn't feel right to
me because usually you know one of the
biggest twists i think about is lily of
the valley in breaking bad and even that
they showed it to us you see walt look
at it so they gave us all the puzzle
pieces to put it together this feels
like there would be too many puzzle
pieces we didn't see that somewhere
along the way cliff had to actually
agree with howard and
that kim is up to something and come up
with this ruse so it doesn't sit right
with me but we'll see
i am curious to see
how far howard is willing to go you know
he tells his wife i will deal with this
one way or another and
when i hear howard say that i think
legal you know uh he's gonna he's gonna
come at him with cease and desist with
restraining orders with the law
i don't see howard is the guy to be that
duplicitous
uh but who knows
yeah i think that for me it's hard to
imagine how they go back to that and how
it would it would play into what happens
next but we'll see i mean like i said i
just hadn't ever thought about it it
never crossed my mind so um
it's something to think about it's it's
something that you know it could be
there could be something there i kind of
i'm leaning away from it as uh you know
how it would be effective but we'll wait
and see
um team magic infinity thank you again
for the 9.99 i agree pete i think this
was one of the first times where kim
felt
duped like she was interested in the
fact her mom seemed to care
but then later found out her mom was
just pulling an act and um
the next one from whisper gaming is is
in the same vein uh
thanks again for the 4.99 yes you got it
kid kim dropped her mom's hand right
when her mom made fun of her for
pretending to be upset in the store
so yeah um
do you
i think we kind of went over that is
there anything more that's come to mind
for either one of you for for add on
that
the one thing that occurred to me as you
were just talking is that i always think
about
when
jimmy kind of betrayed kim and um she
just how much she sticks with jimmy
throughout all this
if she saw her mom kind of pull a
similar trick all the way back then
that kind of tells her this is a thing
that adults do
so she might go into her adulthood kind
of believing that so uh yeah i think
it's a scene i want to keep thinking
about and see what else we can kind of
draw from it
yeah um
jim
oh no
okay
andrew
mc
andrew
mcnama thank you for the 4.99 the store
clerk warns warns jimmy about the bottle
topper being sharp
what are the chances it ends up in
someone's juggler
i i feel like it's low
but you know you're right those two
things
sharpness and
and jugulars they don't really go
together
what do you guys think if you see any
stabbing going on anytime soon
drops it accidentally cuts off
[Laughter]
yeah i i think that um
there's a lot of there's a lot of
there's already a lot of symbolic stuff
going on with that stopper so
i don't i don't think that it's going to
change that way but we'll wait and see i
thought it was kind of funny though
speaking of that how
whenever
he's about to buy the body you think oh
wait maybe this is the stopper that was
in the teaser in episode one not hers
and then he ends up not buying it which
kind of confirms that it is hers that we
saw there
craig otto thank you for the two dollars
do any of you
nervous unconsciously tap your foot
um
i i think so
uh it's not my i'm a hand masher that's
my
that's my nervous habit as i mash my
hands um
what about you guys
oh yeah clear kim does that she's been
doing that for years and howard
apparently
yeah whenever whenever he's in front of
cliff
yeah
uh one more here
crazy protractor beard
thank you for the 699 canadian
no one has discussed when the liquor
store salesman told saul to be careful
with the oh it's the same thing
um
yeah i mean gold teased that we should
watch the one that was already in in the
narrative the one that kim kept after
they they scammed kem ken wins and she's
kept that it's been her trophy
kind of similar to the uh
to the these earrings that she's kept
for
decades and still wears today you know i
mean she she has a she has a tendency to
hold on to things that that have a
specific meaning to her
i've always interpreted it as that was
uh
the scam when she felt alive or whatever
she got out of that that kick that she
got it was to remind her of that
do you guys have any ultimate alternate
um
takes on that
i just
yeah the line about it being sharp did
you guys just interpret it as
a little bit of a wink wink at the
audience that that stopper represents
the thing for kim which has kind of led
her to where she's at now that was kind
of the thing that reactivated this part
of her
that's gotten her um going down this
dark road
and the line was really and that's what
that line was about
yeah that's where i was coming from i
thought it was sort of there as a you
know kind of to play with our our
expectations about whether that one that
we saw at the beginning was was hers or
if it was another one
and yeah and it to me it reminded me
that yeah this is what started it all
you know that one time
scamming ken
led to
this thing we're going to talk about in
a minute right
anna thank you for the five dollars 606
ending mirrors
kim's car crash and arm break in season
three the new episode was how they shot
her car crash
with her rehearsing out loud
the new episode was how they shot her
car crash with her rehearsing out loud
yeah when kim crashed her car a couple
seasons back she was preparing for an
important meeting yeah she was kind of
reversing it out loud
yeah there it is yeah she was kind of
doing that that's a good catch
yeah both uh life-altering moments car
crash after that's when she starts to
rededicate herself to pd here not a car
crash but that u-turn feels like a
pretty pivotal moment for her
we got one here from jeffrey townes and
thanks for you for the ten dollars
canadian seems odd to me that cliff
would be vetting kim after howard told
him of kim and jimmy's misdoings
also howard's wife had a helen pierce
ozark quality about her
i think that
um
howard overlooked
howard and cliff i thought i thought the
assumption was that howard and cliff
both under overlooked
kim's
uh
part in that i think i thought that they
that
howard especially thought it was just
jimmy he didn't bring up kim being
involved even though he was meeting with
kim
jim did you think that the same way i
mean was was
do you think that howard or
i don't think that um
kim was on cliff's radar for what was
going on with howard
yes so i i remember i don't know why i
remember this scene so specifically um
but
i remember that everything howard says
in that scene
to cliff wouldn't give away that kim was
actually involved in this um yeah
though i think
the thing that puts howard on to jimmy
there is kim's involvement so he assumes
that kim and jimmy are working together
i think
but i don't think cliff could get that
from the conversation they had
so jim i had the same assumption until
just now i started thinking about it and
it's possible that howard doesn't yet
think that kim is involved he might just
think that jimmy knew she was having the
meeting and took advantage of that fact
because at the end of season five
when uh howard kind of blames jimmy for
kim's big decision to quit
and she really hated him for that you
know taking that away from her saying
you didn't make a choice here you're
just being manipulated by jimmy he might
still be in that mindset and still think
that she's not really thinking for
herself
um
so
which might he might still have an
inkling that she's involved but i'm just
now considering the possibility
because it actually it does seem that he
is overlooking her because the pi is
following jimmy it's not following kim
so yeah it's possible he's overlooking
her involvement
yeah that's where i was at i thought i
thought that he was completely in the
dark about her being involved
did you have something else jim
no no that makes a lot of sense though
okay
all right uh
tim omen thank you for the five again
much appreciate it um
might have been the last one no here we
got another one
uh
non-nobis solem thank you for the 10 no
question to push just saying thanks well
i appreciate that
thank
you for coming and um
yeah so the vet
caldera
i saw some complaints about this um
that this kind of felt like it was just
sort of wedged in there didn't really
fit
either of you guys of that belief
i mean they had to get the chemical for
their plan somewhere right
yeah that's what i thought i thought he
served served a purpose for the plot
it might have been a little it might
have felt a little bit weird i i thought
this was the first time where some of
this stuff maybe felt a little bit
pandemic um
you know like things felt a little bit
more
disconnected because of the fact that
they were shooting during the pandemic
and
and whatever but i mean
this is the guy you would go to if you
needed something like this right
yeah i think if they walked into the the
clinic and all they had was the
conversation where caldera says you know
i think i'm gonna hang it all up and he
points to the pets and he says that's
what it's all about this would feel
pretty shoehorned in it as just a
mouthpiece to make that point about do
you know why you're doing all this and
you wonder if kim really knows why she's
doing all this if that's all that
happened in this scene i would think
this feels out of place but to your
point it's a logical step in their plan
they need to get that drug
where else would they get it from
besides maybe daniel wermald price if
he's still illegally selling
pharmaceuticals
so the scene worked for me and i i'm a
fan of the caldera character so i was
happy to see him again and give him a
little bit it seems like a lot of
characters this season are getting a
little bit more to do like bill oakley
he's always just jealous of jimmy's
success or laughing at him when things
don't work out and he got that little
bit extra where he got to tell him
that what he did was terrible and here i
feel like we got a little bit more from
caldera than we normally do
yeah and um
did you have anything on that jim
i was gonna ask a question do you guys
so there's this thing at the very
beginning of this scene when we first
pick it up where
jimmy says uh my skin's a little itchy
from that stuff you put on
from
is he talking about the stuff that he
had to put on his skin to look like
howard
is he talking sunburn he had
no
he's talking about the application of
the thing that makes his eyes dilate
oh they've already done it at that point
i think so i think he put it on him
topically or whatever you call it when
you put it on on somebody's skin
okay that that's the way i interpret it
gil what did what did you think
no and i interpreted it the same way
it for some reason didn't occur to me
that the drug could be administered
topically so initially i was thinking
wait so did jimmy take
some medicine but they also for sure not
medicine had to take this drug but they
also had to apply something to his skin
uh maybe to see if he's allergic to it
or something i didn't really think it
through fully but it would make a lot of
sense if it's something you could apply
on the skin
because it would be much easier to get
it into howard's system if that's the
way they're going again hewlett bumps
into him it'd be tough to like slyly
slip a pill into his mouth but a little
something on his arm her hand that could
do it
blow dart gun
yeah
exactly was that your only question
about this jim
uh-huh
okay um so
i did listen to part of the insider
podcast this morning when i was getting
things ready
and uh peter gould did say that this was
important for for him because there was
always this question about
how
jimmy got a hold of this card
you know ed's card the disappear and why
mike didn't know about it and i thought
that was interesting that he brought
that up because we don't actually see
how that happens we see that he has the
book we see that he's trying to sell it
we see that it's coded
and we also see that it shows up in the
season or the episode one teaser when
they go through saul's house when
they're they're taking a stuff
but there's no conclusion on on if it if
it passes hands or what's going on so
what do you guys think about that what
do you think is going on there
you can go first jim if you want i mean
as to how they'll get it i
i just
buy it from him or
he's gonna end up dead somehow and
they'll find maybe the cipher or the key
for this thing um
yeah it's anybody's guess
yeah i agree with that it just it just
feels like a seed that's been planted
and you can mat you can imagine any
number of ways that he can get a hold of
that book if he's looking to retire and
sell off all his assets
i don't see why jimmy couldn't be a
buyer especially if they get that
sandpiper money god i think that's a
pretty expensive book
yeah i wonder i wonder about that it's
four
oh you think it's what the 20 000 was
for oh at first i did before oh yeah
okay
yeah that makes sense um i think that
would probably be a fair price or or
you're talking about something like that
this isn't something that you're going
to pick up for 50 or 100 you know what i
mean you're talking
it has earning potential built in right
oh yeah it's an investment yeah um
yeah so i just wonder if this is the
last we'll see of him or
if there's going to be a continuation of
that i guess
i mean would you think it would be would
it make sense if it just shows up there
later i mean would that be enough
as far as
ed's card being introduced into into the
universe
i feel like i can see it working either
way like i don't necessarily need
especially this season where it feels
like when we can assume what happened
between steps they've been tending to
kind of skip ahead especially with the
lalo story so i wouldn't put it past
them to
just they've given us enough information
and
at some point when we see them building
up their business
or building up uh using their sandpiper
money if they get it
um just an offhand mention for acquiring
that book i don't know that we
necessarily need to see more but it's
definitely possible
yeah
what do you think jim anything
we'll see um
yeah i don't think it's necessary either
now they've sort of half connected the
dots but
i i would say it's more likely than not
that we'll see more of it
yeah that's kind of where i'm at too
after hearing that before i was just
like well we we saw it it showed up and
yeah it makes sense that they get it one
way or the other but now after hearing
them mention that i'm wondering if we'll
see something else
magic infinity
you say something i i was gonna say they
left uh
sort of a dangling thread there right
with the fact that it's encrypted so
that's true
they can't read it if they get it they
they would have to figure out how to to
understand it
thank you for the 499. i think the bets
lying about the caffeine intake in
relation to the drug will play a part
for howard maybe maybe give him a bad
reaction and we did mention this earlier
um
i yeah i i i i'm i'm still not sure like
i think
it could just
it could just be that it gets out of
control you know i mean that they that
they have a scare
but yeah it could be it could lead to
something much worse
if if that's what that i mean i think
that they i think him making the point
about caffeine it just sort of seemed
like we were supposed to pick up on that
yeah i said uh p you and i did a
preseason podcast like a preview thing
and i was
looking for something
beyond the pale to happen in this scheme
for me to really turn on
kim or jimmy or both
that might be it man if they kill howard
unintentionally that would definitely
set me off
i mean the nature of doing something
like this is that and them showing us
that they meticulously planned
everything out and that there's they
just got it all figured out you know
that we saw a little bit of that go
wrong here
but um
yeah
something has to go wrong something out
of their control that they don't intend
because otherwise they would just
uh pull it off and everything would be
fine
and that's not that doesn't really jive
with the fact that we don't know where
kim's at in four years later and things
like that right
ask k agarwal thank you for the one
dollars i appreciate it um
beyond this situation we we touched a
little bit about it we do get to see kim
in action in the pro bono uh arena
and she does a pretty good job of
impressing clifford maine who has a
i mean he basically has what she's been
looking for um this is what really is uh
kind of fascinating about this episode
is that
this offer pretty much
would guarantee that she could do the
work that she wanted to do
and not in the in the sandpiper money
would be you know not important at all
and she seems excited about it
jimmy is is excited about it everybody
realizes what a great opportunity that
this is but they don't even
briefly talk about
not going through with the plan that
they're doing which is just really
frustrating in a way
to watch yeah it's funny because we've
been in it they've kind of played it on
the fence the last few episodes
when cliff goes for the idea kim says
well i don't think he's going to be
writing any checks so we could at least
tell ourselves okay it's not exactly
that she doesn't need the sandpiper
money you could still argue that it'll
be very beneficial for getting this all
started but now they just cranked it up
all the way to
yes they could walk away right now
and she could have everything that she
supposedly wants
but it's become very clear that
destroying howard is not about money
and this is the second time they've done
that in this show right they mirrored
that with
this just mirroring what jimmy went
through when he got the job at uh davis
maine
he had everything he wanted right um
except for maybe that partner in crime
that he wanted
because
you know he could have had the life that
that chuck sort of wanted for him and
that i think he might have wanted at one
time but he gave it all up in favor of
scamming
it also mirrors walter white because he
says he's doing it for the money for his
family and of course i think pretty
early on there was the offer from
gretchen and elliot to help them
financially and he turned them down so
this show i mean these shows love to
poke and prod at what characters say
and basically back them into a wall and
say you're saying you want this all
right here it is
and now you're really put to the test is
that true
yeah and i i just really want to really
quickly want to get to this one uh
one super chat before i forget about it
craig otto thank you again for three
dollars have any of you ever taken a
substance that dilated your pupils
and uh
i've taken them
at uh the the eye doctor they do that on
purpose don't they that seems like
something that happens
yeah
i went a few weeks ago actually and had
that done and i forgot about that step
in the process so i didn't have
sunglasses or anything so i was walking
back to my apartment and it was it was
brutal like i couldn't open my eyes for
about 15 minutes
yeah it's been a while i i maybe three
or three or four years ago i went and
got a pair of glasses and yeah i think
that i remember them doing that to me
i won't comment on any other substances
that might have done that
hopefully howard brought his sunglasses
otherwise maybe he walks out of hhm
can't see where he's going walks right
off a cliff or or something like that
yeah and we have a couple more here um
i'm trying to i'm trying to hold the the
thread on what's going on with kim and
knock these out at the same time
subversibly surreal thank you for the
4.99 what about the break until july
it's terrible because it's going to be a
cliffhanger on monday
yeah i'm not really that broken up about
it um
i i don't know this is a show that
rewards patience anyways so i i feel
like uh i'm not worried that it's gonna
be a letdown when it comes
you know i i feel like
yeah i'd like to see it all right now
and um
you know continue making videos and
talking to my friends on here about
about it and stuff like that but
um
it's not the end of the world
how are you guys how are you guys
managing the uh
the impending separation anxiety for
i think it's six weeks is it six weeks
or seven weeks that they're gonna be
gone
i mean look if you can't handle seven
weeks wait until the end of next chunk
cause
that's forever
no i i think like what you said earlier
pete about their cliffhangers and the
way they usually do them
i've seen good cliffhangers and i've
seen bad cliffhangers and this show
always does the good ones where you know
what happens
and now it's how is that gonna affect
everybody around it you know how it
changes the situation um in a way where
you can go
oh boy and then that cascades over here
and this person's gonna be mad and it's
gonna affect them
those are the good kind of cliffhangers
so i think it'll be very rewarding to
see next week's episode and the wait is
not that long so i am not
sweating the cliffhanger at all
what do you think gail
life has taught me over the years that
the anticipation is usually the best
part of the journey
i used to uh live a few hours from my
hometown and the place i was living i
was not happy so every weekend i would
drive about three hours back home and
when i got there
go to the bar hang out with my friends
nothing special but the three hour drive
back was always the best part i was so
excited to go home so this is going to
be
like a seven hour drive back home
and i'm excited for better call saul and
i can wait a few weeks for it yeah
yeah i'm a little uh i'm a little tired
um
making
non-stop content too i think it'll be
good for that to get a little bit of a
breather and um be psyched up for the
end because
i'm really looking forward to it and
there's a part of me that doesn't want
it to end either you know um
so
we'll see uh thank you pamela phillips
for the five dollars appreciate that
thanks for
coming in and uh
saying hello
uh there it is i couldn't find this one
um
duke tiger one thank you for the 1999
euro how can they give the physical
photos to howard because if he tries to
verify them with the judge
want to be clear that jimmy set it all
up i mean the judge obviously doesn't
that obviously doesn't know it's not or
obviously knows it's not himself right
yeah and i think at least my take on
this is that it's not really to it's
only it only has to work for a minute
and it only has to make him
look crazy
he doesn't have to be right or wrong or
anything else he just has to look like
he is a drug crazed person that's coming
up with wild theories about something
that didn't happen
what do you what do you think jim
oh yeah man i i cannot wait for the
scene where
howard tries to take it to this judge or
whatever is actually going to happen
there uh because yeah he's going to look
insane and
you know the proof will be right there
like it's it's not the guy right the
judge knows that was not me
so it's not gonna work right
but it is gonna be super entertaining to
watch
if anything an outside observer might
look at that and say howard did you
stage these photos to try and make jimmy
look guilty and try and make it look
like the judge was in on this
so yeah i think you guys are right that
it just needs to work for a minute and
just cast enough doubt on the case
that
howard can't be a part of this
okay well
let's move on um
we're getting
how are you guys on time because we're
getting up up there a little bit we have
a couple more points here on the on the
uh
recap
yeah i'm good yeah i'm gonna keep going
okay
so yeah so they have this plan i think
we we've kind of already gone through
what that is i think we can all agree
that it's going to be some kind of uh
all this has been leading up to howard
having a very public breakdown
it seems like it's set up pretty good um
kim has got it all
she's got this partner in crime she's
got this husband that loves her that
supports her he doesn't care if they
they get this money or not he's just
happy to be hanging out
and um
now things have turned in her career
to where she could have that if she
wants it to
and it all comes down to
this meeting she has to go to with cliff
it's on the same day as d-day
but you know she doesn't need to be
there she doesn't have to do anything on
d-day it's already been it's already set
in motion
but then jimmy learns as he goes to the
liquor store that the pictures they took
won't be good won't work because
the judge has a broken arm and
everyone's going to know that so when
they see the photos they're going to
know they're fake
this leads to the point of no return
that we talked about in the beginning
her decision
to ditch the meeting
make a u-turn and
go back to try to make sure that howard
gets his
at the end um
just yeah
uh gil what do you what do you got there
uh first i thought the way the scene
played out was pretty entertaining
it uh with the uh with the lollow scene
we talked about earlier i kind of
laughed a little bit when lalo and
casper kind of stare at each other and
then casper just turns and runs away and
similarly here when the camera pans over
and you just see the zafiro anejo box
and jimmy isn't there anymore because he
just turned tail and ran
and then of course the the crux of the
scene is that not only have they set it
up so that kim doesn't need this money
anymore but now they've very explicitly
made a choice between the two
because you've got to think that not
showing up to that meeting
may take her involvement off the table
maybe there's a way to
rescue it afterward i'm assuming kim
believes in this moment in this very
hectic moment that she can have both you
know she but but ultimately
the more important thing to her very
clearly is taking down howard
so i think
yeah it's
very curious to see what the fallout is
going to be but the important thing here
is that she made that choice
what do you think jim
yeah i mean to add on to that it's it's
you know important that that she made
that choice but she definitely knows
that it
it hinders her chances too right it's
it's not like oh i can salvage this
later it'll be fine
she knows this is a big deal the choice
she's making um
so yeah i i was
oh man kim i i'm always sad to see these
choices that she makes right because i
want a good life for her and i don't
feel like this is the path to that good
life
and every time she makes it i mean the
choice of marrying jimmy the choice of
scamming with him like every time she
chooses jimmy and i know it's the wrong
choice
yeah and i mean i i i was i'm with you
on that i i thought that she i thought
that
kim is smart uh you know she she can she
can look at this she can assess the
situation proper properly i think and
in that moment when she's struggling to
make the decision i believe that she
comes to the conclusion that if she
makes that choice
cliff's offer is done like maybe it's
possible maybe she's hoping there's
something there but i don't think she
can make the turn
without acknowledging the fact that
there's a very real possibility that
she's throwing that away
and deciding i don't care this is the
more important thing
and
man i mean
is the setup there do we know enough
about her to to for this to make sense
is this just humans being human and
doing things that don't make sense
you know where where does this leave you
at the end of this episode
i think for me just a devil's advocate
for a second for why
she might i think such a theme for kim
has been lying to herself where she
thinks that she can do good on one side
and do a little bad over here i do think
it's possible that she might come out of
this
and try to rescue what she can from the
cliff deal and maybe this is the time
when she realizes i can't always have my
cake and eat it too this is the time
when it finally fails so i think that's
a possibility
though either way she very clearly is
prioritizing the howard operation over
that which i think is the important
thing and in terms of do i buy it
i do and i think with every decision kim
makes like this i'm always left
scratching my head wondering why
but it's never felt inappropriate i
think that's a tight needle that the
show has thread which is it's doing
these surprising things but they can't
be so surprising that they break the
reality and you don't buy it anymore and
at least with kim for me it always comes
right up to the edge where i don't
necessarily understand the decision
always
but i believe it and instead of just
saying this makes no sense i'll instead
think about it and try to understand the
decision and look forward to the next
revelations about her character not
necessarily views into her past but just
what is her psychology that lets her do
this sort of thing
yeah another thing we talked about pete
in that preview podcast we did because i
have long
felt like i was losing my grip on where
kim stands and why she's making the
choices she's making and the turning
point for me on her was kind of that the
decision to marry jimmy um right off the
back of him betraying her and everything
uh
and you and i talked that through in
that podcast i think i i understood
where you were coming from and and i
think i'm a little more moderated on
that now but
sometimes i do have a hard time reading
her um
i i think
this
uh flashback that we get at the
beginning of this episode sheds a lot of
light on
who she is and that complex relationship
that she has had with
you know fudging the truth um through
her mother through her childhood
it it kind of goes a long way toward
smoothing that over for me that this is
a part of her and it kind of always has
been even if she was able to
push it to the side for so long uh long
enough to become you know this powerful
attorney at powerful law firms um
but ultimately that is a part of her and
it's just taking the driver's seat at
this point
yeah i think what we were talking about
then and and what what like a lot of
that was dawning on me when we were
having that conversation because we both
had just done a full re-watch and we had
all that stuff fresh in our heads
and and yeah i think the thing that
stood out to me
you know that came to me was that they
they're outsiders you know as much as
kim seems like she fits in that world
she she kind of doesn't you know we know
where she even before we didn't have
this this this flashback of this season
we saw last last seasons and we heard
her tell uh rich whenever she went into
the interview that
you know how she sort of ran away from
from that life that she thought she was
gonna be stuck in there in nebraska and
um anyway i thought that was part of the
connection part of why she chose jimmy
in some of those situations is you know
when you're an outsider it you know it's
nice to have that kind of comfort of
someone who who understands that
perspective and
you know we see that it does like like
you just said that this this does really
kind of make that make a lot more sense
you know not only you know was her
mother
uh
you know kind of unreliable and and not
the kind of mother that she wanted to
have but she also had some of those same
tendencies that jimmy has so it does
make sense i mean i think
there's a thing about marrying your
mother or whatever and maybe maybe
there's a little bit of that going on
with with kim there
um let's see
so so gil you were talking there about
um you know her her wanting to be able
to have it both ways you know
and yeah and i think that that is true
you know i think that she
she sees herself as being able to pull
it off in some ways i just i i think
it's specifically with this i i just
thought that
the way that it's set up is that you
know it's a spur-of-the-moment thing and
um
you know like what i was thinking is you
know she has
she could just keep going you know
and and if she just keeps going then
okay everything everything that she
claims to want she'll have
you know what i mean
but when she turns she puts all of that
stuff at risk she puts her relationship
with jimmy she puts her future in pro
bono all of it you know
at risk
and specifically because
she'll get the same things but she'll
also get to take down howard
and yeah it's just fascinating and like
you said it's like
none of it doesn't make sense um
it's just
it's just that i mean it could in in in
the instant when you think about it
because you think you know what a
character is but in in reality we we
don't really know that much about kim
that's been a big part of this whole
lead-up you know is that we we thought
we did we we applied things that we
thought made sense to the character that
we were watching
but we didn't actually know much at all
about who she was or how she ended up
there
and i wondered i'm sorry
yeah i was just going to say do you
think we're gonna find out more of that
or do you think that this is sort of
going we've sort of reached
the end of that road and now we're just
gonna be looking at consequences
it it to me it would feel a little
disappointing if we don't get a little
more understanding of her as a character
or maybe even more than that what i'd
like to see is her coming to terms with
herself
kind of like walter white at the end of
breaking bad when he finally confessed
to his wife
he says i did it for she cuts him off
she says do not tell me you did this for
your family and he says i did it for
myself it made me feel alive and that
was the moment when he finally
acknowledged why he was really doing all
this
you can't do that too many times i feel
like having character is just say out
loud here is what i'm all about i
finally came to this realization
but i would like to see some kind of
reconciliation or some kind of
something for kim i don't know exactly
what i'm looking for but whether it's us
understanding her more
or there just being some moment of
clarity i think would be would be nice
because it is
she is such a mysterious character
because we're watching and at first we
think we're watching her change she's
becoming more like jimmy maybe she's
being
inspired by him in some ways but then we
start to wonder well is she changing we
don't really know what's in her mind so
this might just be her getting more in
touch with what was already there and
this flashback definitely puts that into
the mix
so
i guess i'm looking kind of to quote kim
she left her hometown she was looking
for more doesn't know exactly what that
is i'm looking for more i don't know
exactly what it will be but i'm sure the
writers won't disappoint
i think there's a real opportunity here
with
why did she leave um and we know kind of
why she left generally but like how did
that all go down um i could see a real
parallel between how she feels about
jimmy and how she felt about her mother
back when she decided i've had enough of
this life i'm gonna go make a new one
um i think there's a real opportunity to
do that as a flashback
at the same time that we're seeing the
parallels here with jimmy that could be
pretty satisfying
[Music]
yeah that's interesting you know i i
thought about her having to flee
but i haven't i hadn't really thought
about her just
choosing to walk away no not for a while
anyways i mean there was obviously a an
idea that maybe she would get fed up
with jimmy
and she would want to get out of the out
of the relationship and and when she
doubled down and got married that kind
of that kind of made that seem like a
little less likely i mean they seem to
be
like
genuinely in love even if there's some
scamming and different dynamics going on
in between them um
you know that the idea of her
of her repeating the the pattern of
running away from home and running away
from new from albuquerque i mean the
situation is a little bit different when
you're a teenager or you're 18 or
whatever it's pretty easy to go
somewhere new and start over
as a you know as a professional working
professional maybe that's a little more
complicated but yeah i hadn't really i
hadn't really thought of that as like
you know maybe they get away with the
scam but maybe she decides to leave
anyways because
this place is done for her after that
that's kind of interesting
where do you guys stand on the theory i
haven't heard people floating it as much
lately but before the season i feel like
one of the very popular predictions was
that kim was gonna take the money and
run and abandon jimmy do either of you
think that's in the mix at all or if you
uh i never really
bought into that theory but kim is such
a mystery you never know
yeah i never bought into that one either
um
i don't see it i don't see it
it's funny because you know it's a
female character so i feel like i have a
natural blind spot for certain things um
i i i've had some
i've had some like i i never really
bought into it to answer the question um
i've heard some people make
more compelling cases than than than
others and but the one thing
that uh
that i think that stood out to me as far
as where she might
be playing things a little bit
differently is is the way that she was
really against the idea of him going to
uh
to the to the desert or you know to go
and pick up the money
i feel like that there was something
that happened there that all kind of got
pushed to the side because of the way
that played out
you know i i don't think there's a long
con going on i don't think she met jimmy
mcgill and thought oh i can take this
guy for millions of dollars because that
doesn't really make sense right she met
him in the
in the in the uh
the mail room when he didn't have
anything he lived in the back of a
nail salon
but
i think that they're that they're that
her motivations are more complex than
than just that she just wants to
uh you know
do the right thing
do this law practice for the unfortunate
and live happily ever after with jimmy
does that make sense
yeah no it does i agree with all that
yeah and i don't think there's any kind
of long con going on
all right there's a couple there's one
super chat that's been waiting for a
really long time so let me get to that
and uh
ej160e
five dollars thank you for that do you
think howard's pi actually is an actor
who's part of saul and kim's plot
in the back in black and white photos
actually are all taken by the unm camera
dude
we've touched on this a couple times
already
it's not clear
there's there's there's there's things
on both and you know both sides that
don't quite make sense
uh we all kind of lean to him not being
an actor but it's definitely possible
so thank you for the super chat
oh where'd the other one go
sorry guys i i uh there it is
steve mueller 4.99 kim carrick kim kim's
character is mired in symmetry we don't
know kim just like she doesn't know
herself she leaves her mom just like she
leaves jimmy
um
[Music]
we don't know kim just like she doesn't
know herself yes i mean i think that
we've touched on that a couple of times
and i think uh
you know there there there is uh there
is an element to that
you know she's she's gone through a lot
of changes when you think about it in
the story and and part of that was
discovering that
the perfect um
you know the perfect job at the perfect
firm wasn't really for her and that's
why she she got into the pro bono stuff
so she had she's she's constantly
evolving um she leaves her mom just like
she leaves jimmy that's what we were
just talking about do you guys have
anything else you want to add to to that
the only thing i'd add is uh she leaves
her mom just like she leaves jimmy i
don't know if we 100 know that yet
and i know that at least before this
flashback my read on the initial
flashback
because they showed it in the same
episode where she decided to marry jimmy
my thought was that maybe things didn't
go well with her mother so
as a result of that she's very
reluctant to let people go in her life
so she doesn't want to lose jimmy the
way she lost her mother and that's why
she doubled down on that relationship
so i definitely agree that there's
connections between the two her
relationship with her mother is
definitely influencing her now i'm just
not 100 sure how yet
uh and maybe we'll get a better idea by
the end of the series
yeah i think it's a sensible take that
um
it could be you know the part of why she
she she leans into the idea of marriage
is because things went bad with her mom
as well
you got anything you want to add to that
one jim
yeah i mean i think like uh
the idea that we could see another
flashback with how she left her mom uh
doesn't necessarily have to say
hey she's doing the exact same thing
with jimmy she could be doing the
opposite you know this could this could
be
reflective of positive growth or or some
other
uh
difference in how she treated her mother
versus jimmy but i think
yeah that that's the one flashback that
i would like to see is how that ended
yeah i agreed um we got one more here
and then we'll start to we'll start to
wind things down and talk about uh what
was going to happen next
harrison thank you for the five dollars
how will they get the inflatable liberty
statue from the kettleman's there may be
they may be involved with the rebound
strategy from kim yeah i was wondering
about that too um
whenever i was cutting clips for the
last video you know i was looking
through
shots of the um the old
the old saw goodman office that that
that's in the future from where we're at
right now and i was reminded that they
never did get that yet and it reminded
me of the book you know we we've had
these um
priester eggs as they call them you know
the things that showed up in the uh the
opening sequence and then they show up
and
turn out to be important in uh episodes
later
i think the only one that i didn't see
something in it was the um maybe the
fourth episode or the the fifth one of
those two there every other every other
one had clearly had something that was
in jimmy's house whenever they went
through it
and um
yeah the inflatable liberty statue is a
surprise still a mystery do you gill do
you think that
that means the kettleman's will return
i don't know it's a similar question as
that black book
do we need to see more steps in between
we saw the book and actually see jimmy
acquire it i feel like between the two
we're more likely to see the black book
because that just feels like a more
important thing
for saul goodman than the statue of
liberty um but uh yeah the kettlebells
it feels like the nachos dad question i
feel like we've seen everything we need
to see from them
but
it's a possibility maybe if it even
shows up there's like a final jimmy to
saul goodman transformation montage
maybe there's a second there where we
see him handing a stack of cash to the
kettleman's and walking away with the
statue of liberty
i feel like a due for a montage
we were talking about that last week but
go ahead jim
yeah i haven't seen one uh in a while i
i was gonna say i i think it could just
be the inspiration you know he saw that
and he thinks back to now it's a good
idea and he goes out and
finds another one i i two of these have
to exist in the world right
uh
or here's what i really want to see i
want to see him send francesca out to
get that thing because that would just
kill her she would just
shrivel up inside knowing he's going to
put that outside
that's the moment when she became saul
goodman's secretary
yeah
oh boy
yeah like i said she's on her own mini
uh walter white to heisenberg uh highway
there
it is funny i like that i like that a
lot um
let's see see yes thank you for the five
dollars i see a final twist coming to
the con judge has a twin who's the one
in the cask
the one in the cast putting a cast on
the actor will ironically be what undoes
kim and jimmy
um jamie
vehemently agreeing with this theory oh
wow
that's a hell of a theory
yeah
the old twin plot
huh the old twin for the body double
dress up like the wrong one plot
it has been such a body double heavy
season
lalo gus
jimmy as howard and now casamiro
i don't know how many is too many i'm
not sure
we haven't gotten there yet i could say
that yeah i i i haven't tired of it yet
but but you're right there there is a
threshold and hopefully they know where
that line is and they don't cross it
ej160e thank you for the two dollars
rather be married to
cheryl hamlin
or skyler white
oh what do you think jim
boy
can i pick what era of skylar because
she seemed pretty cool for a while there
uh
this is a very difficult question
do i get the house if i marry cheryl
yeah that's a that's a good that's
something to think about i was trying to
figure out how can i answer this
question without having to judge either
of these characters and i figured okay
there we go that's my that's my escape
hatch
yeah i mean you know the
cheryl is we don't we don't know a lot
about her but she is uh
icy i mean
there's not much
to warm you up to her besides that of of
course that that's a beautiful
actor who plays the role you know i mean
like um
i guess if she's
you know the people have types and if
you're if you're into that type then i i
could say that you would be more
attracted to her
i mean skyler kind of gets a a a raw
deal in a way you know i mean um
i don't know that
we could say that howard put cheryl
through those same kinds of things you
know
um
yeah that's a tough question uh
it's a good one though i'm glad you
asked it thank you for that um there's
another one here
i just saw uh
craig otto thank you for the two dollars
speaking of casemiro talk about john
ennis uh this is an actor who's been in
a lot of stuff and it's been a long time
since i've watched mr show
and of course he's he's aged um in that
amount of time but uh did you guys
recognize this guy who was playing lenny
the um
the body double for
uh
the judge did you guys know him
no
i didn't i don't think i've seen much
that he's in i have not seen mr show i
know it's shameful
uh yeah it's been so long since i saw it
like he he looked vague vaguely uh
you know
familiar but i didn't know that it was
that until i saw it but there's another
thing about him
the the actor who plays aaron brill
and davis and maine that's his daughter
oh cool that's kind of interesting a
father and daughter
acting uh
family there he did do a good job in the
scene he was pretty funny like when uh
the the girl doing his makeup was like
you're doing a great job and he's like i
am aren't i yeah that was the best line
and they said that in the um insider
podcast they said that he improvised
that that that wasn't on the page that's
awesome
yeah and and jim i i would recommend um
mr show it's i don't know how long it's
been i i remember i visited my brother
maybe eight or ten years ago and we
watched we watched some of it in the
background and i i i couldn't remem i
mean i couldn't i knew it was hilarious
the first time i watched it but i i
couldn't believe how well it just still
is
really was just as funny and i'm sure
now 10 years later it still would work
especially if you're
obviously a bob odenkirk fan then you
know it's something yeah david cross i
love him yeah so yeah
so i i guess then we are we're getting
getting a little long now um
let's think about how to wrap this thing
up if you guys have questions as you
you're you're saving them now is a good
time to
try to shoot them off because
we won't be around too much longer
i mean the biggest thing from this at
the end was like where does it go from
here and and and then one of the side
questions i have kicking around in my
head is
if this all falls down if everything
breaks down around um
this plan and it goes badly
is there is there a situation where
there's a the second half of the season
where the kim storyline is completely
wrapped up
like the present day kim storyline
can you imagine that can you imagine
when you're writing the season you have
a character like tony dalton and you got
a
person like ray seahorn on the roster
and then you get to the point where you
have to
remove them
i mean you would want to make that last
as long as you could wouldn't you
yeah i mean aside from the gene stuff
that's got to be
the hammer for this entire show right i
mean it's kim and jimmy
yeah but it doesn't it does kind of feel
like the the kim
is is
is is coming to some sort of at least
present day conclusion doesn't it
well do you think i feel like there's
been a lot of speculation that
the lalo stuff is going to collide with
the jimmy kim story so maybe we mostly
wrap up with howard
but then somehow the two get intertwined
yeah that could make sense where or
you know they're they're they're licking
their wounds and things have gone badly
and they're
looking for an exit strategy and lalo
comes in to
pull them back into something else
before they have a chance to to go for
it maybe especially with mike having
gone to her that feels like a seed that
looks like now it's only going to
get revisited in the second half of the
season
yeah because i mean that that
i just like
i want i'd obviously want to have
more racy horn more kim
in the story
but
there is there is a uh you know there is
a transformation going on with jimmy
mcgill
and he does sort of have to
you know he has to experience some
things i would say that are going to
break his spirit or what however you
want to describe it to to kind of be
the kind of guy who lives in that
um you know he lives in that
in that mansion with the golden toilet i
mean
yeah he's got to get pulled back into
the underworld too right
yeah
yeah it's pretty wild it's it's a weird
place to be you know there's a lot of
this a lot of people complaining about
the setup about the um
the slow pace which i i'm not really
sure
how they got through the first two
seasons if that's what they're thinking
but um
yeah
there's a lot of there's a lot that's
going to have to unfold between now and
the back half of the season
yeah it's starting to get to that point
where it feels like
i'm i'm uh i have not had a problem with
the pacing i'm enjoying it and i feel
like it's pretty in line with previous
seasons but you do start to do the math
and you're like
all right we're getting close to the end
so uh what's going to happen here
yeah it you know setup is for a payoff
and and
that that does need to
happen
and and they do have to resolve some
things i mean i i don't think that they
need to you know hold our hands through
four years of
saul practicing and
to the day that he meets you know walter
white or whatever but i do think they
need to to jump ahead a little bit
at least in in in teasers so we get a
little bit of a different perspective on
that stuff
rod kiefer thank you for the 499 did kim
you turn from good choice road on to
hinky dinky boulevard
hanky dink
uh that was the store that she worked at
i think or the gas station right
he has a cashier or that's what she said
was uh that was like her best
hope if she were to stay where she was
was to end up with a job at hanky dinky
or something like that yeah that's what
i thought
and yeah me and jim were talking before
we came home we were saying about i was
telling him when i was writing my script
for my video yesterday there were so
many opportunities to just pull those
old bcses and you know
kim makes her her u-turn to bad choice
road and you know there was like it just
felt like there was a an inordinate
amount of
uh you know
opportunities to quote the titles of
previous episodes
and and things like that
yeah kim decides not to take a half
measure and takes a u-turn down bad
choice road
yeah
it's just
she's got an axe to grind yeah yeah i i
did i did uh it was funny because i i
avoided axe to grind in the beginning of
it and then when i got towards the end
of the video i was like okay i just this
this is an elephant in the room kind of
situation here i'm just going to say it
because if i don't then you know i'm
going to have like 50 comments about it
that how did you not point out the fact
that what's going on with kim
is the title of the episode it's
one weird little thing i'm curious about
going into the second half of the season
are they going to keep up the title
template of blank and blank
because if they don't it opens up the
possibility for a theory i had which is
that in breaking bad i think season two
episode eight was called better call
saul where they introduced saul goodman
are we going to have an episode of
better call saul named breaking bad
hmm
i like it yeah i wondered about that you
know at times before and and you're
right i i hadn't really made the
connection that the and
convention would stop that there was a
wrench in that
yeah
uh speaking of that the better call saul
stuff um there was a lot of speculation
that maybe jesse or walt might show up
in this episode because of the timing of
the different names of episodes um
the things that were happening in them
obviously that didn't happen do you
think they're saving that for a
particular
moment
and if so
strategically speaking i i i was talking
to kiwi the other day and before the
episode came out and and that's where i
was i was saying that i thought a kim
thing was coming
because we're getting to the end of her
story and i thought we'd see another one
of those
and then i thought that that there's
going to be i think that they're going
to do walt and jesse
probably next week because of the fact
that that'll be such a big that'll
create a lot of buzz for the for the
downtime you know what i mean
people hear oh walt and jesse came back
that gives them a chance to re-watch the
you know or watch the first six or seven
episodes and get ready for the big
closeout because you know people are
going to talk about that i think
that's it though i don't have any like
you know other good reason for that to
happen before um
or in any other particular episode
yeah makes a lot of sense the one thing
i'd add is that i see a lot of people
predicting when they'll show up by
looking at the cast list on imdb but i
can tell you that list is not
trustworthy because last night's episode
i was watching on amazon and i just
moved my mouse and it pops up with a
cast list and i figured that's got to be
trustworthy it's right in the amazon
video viewer and it told me that we were
seeing kai
when we were clearly seeing casper once
people pointed that out to me i was like
i don't think it looks like kai but it
says kai right there so i think amazon
just pulls it from imdb
yeah two things on what you just said
there one is that walt and jesse were
credited on imdb in episode one i
believe
and the other thing is i thought i got
spoiled on
this upcoming episode because someone
wrote that the actor who played kai
prophesies that or you know he posted on
instagram that he was going to die in
this episode and then he didn't even
show up so yeah you can't really
i was like really kind of pissed that
you know because you probably understand
this uh
gill that anytime anything gets spoiled
someone just runs to the comment section
for some reason and starts posting it
yeah and then when i'm scrolling through
there i i just inevitably will see it
like there's no way to i kind of got
over that a while ago you know that it's
just that's part of the job is that that
stuff gets
gets ruined for you but um
yeah that was kind of a funny twist when
it turned out to be casper i was like oh
i guess the actor who play i didn't look
into it i don't know if he actually said
that but someone definitely
made a post and and said that kai the
guy actor who played kaid said that
kai's death was coming up or something
like that
we got a couple of a couple of more
super chats and then we'll start to wind
down guys um so
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna go forever here if you if
you have a super chat question now is
the time because i think we'll
we'll try to get out of here in like the
next 10 minutes is that all right with
you guys
yeah
all right sue's be art or sue's bart
depending on how you read it 9.99 thank
you will kim's dad appear or his
influence be explained
she and jimmy watched ice station zebra
and she said my dad loves this or this
is my dad's favorite
speaking of the dad in present tense um
that's a good question i vaguely
remembered her saying that about ice
station zebra but i
i never had a good
explanation about what's going on with
her father do you guys have a theory for
that
she have to be real young right
if that were the case
yeah i mean we're seeing her she i mean
at the point of the flashback she seems
to not have a father in her life yeah
even that first one right so yeah
yeah and that i don't know i think
that's age 15 i think is what that was
so yeah she would he would had to leave
left her life
you know when she was 12 or something
like that
do we know that the father wasn't around
or i guess if the mother didn't show up
for hours since she was waiting outside
her school yeah a good bet would be that
their father's not around at that point
probably yeah
yeah i don't think it's confirmed in any
way but that was the impression i got
from that one it was just her and and
then she you know when she tells aker
the story about being woke up in the
middle of the night and having to leave
right
it sounded like it was you know her
mother was taking care of her by herself
i guess to answer this question i don't
necessarily need to see more about her
dad at this point my son
it would seem that she remembers him
fondly if she's revisiting this movie so
many years later and if he left at a
really young age and all she has is
positive memories of her of all she has
is positive memories with him
and
the little we know is that maybe that's
where her love of movies came from and
it's just a small explanation of her
personality i would kind of be okay if
that's all we know i do want to know
more about kim whether it's her
relationship with her father or
something else
whatever they have to offer i'm curious
to say
anything to add there jim
no i'm good
all right and there's two more here
craig otto two dollars one more today
please follow gilligan's projects
yeah i don't know if there's i mean
before he came back for season six i
remember hearing him say that he had a
new story that he was writing that he
was developing that he hadn't told
anybody about it yet or even pitched it
but he had been working on it
i'll definitely watch anything that he
that he makes um peter gould as well and
thomas schnells and all those guys um
i don't think that would be a problem
i'll definitely be looking into it and i
think it'll probably be
worth uh
worth covering
um
blue bke 199 thank you possible axe was
gifted to the cousins from lalo
that would have been a little over the
top if if he would have been if he would
have been
swinging the silver axe
that they had um
in breaking bad that might have been a
little too much of a
of a
heavy-handed uh ham-handed maybe um
object to introduce into the universe
all right um
let's see i think that we could probably
at 10 30 that sounds like a pretty good
time i want to thank you guys for for
coming on with me today um had pretty
good attendance that's always fun to see
i'll give you a chance so you can both
plug your
your regular shows your regular gigs gil
you can go ahead first
sure if you like to watch stuff about
better call saul about movies and about
other tv shows you can go to my youtube
channel one take if you prefer to listen
to stuff you can look up this the
podcast saw cast which i do with a
couple of my brothers and we break down
every episode uh every week so uh and
pete thank you for having me on and jim
it was awesome doing this with you again
yeah it is uh and it's a good podcast by
the way i like thank you uh
so i also have a podcast a better cast
saul i do with my wife every wednesday
after the episode comes out
uh take a couple days to break it down
and then
get on the mics and record uh so yeah
you can check that out by searching for
better cast saul on
any podcast portal uh a podcast app or
go to baldmove.com
yeah and i i i you know i bring you guys
on because i enjoy that stuff and i
definitely recommend it to
everyone
i think that
not really sure we're definitely going
to be having a big one next week
there's a possibility that we're going
to keep this going through
maybe not weekly during the downtime but
if there's a reason you know maybe we'll
do some speculation or something
in the time between and then we'll
definitely be back on
the second half of the season
tuesday seems to work a little better
it's kind of a it's kind of a rush to
get to it but it kind of fits better for
the rest of the week and
we've been able to do that so we'll be
trying to do this every tuesday at 9 00
pm
and
hope to see you all back again
thanks to everyone who gave us super
chats that helps out a lot and we'll see
you next week thanks